I'm Jason Momoa, and Smarles is popping my cherry. Smart less. Jason, you look, why do you look so clean cut today? Yeah, you look really good. Because I washed. I'm fresh from the shower. I'm glad we were a little delayed today because I was running a little behind. And it occurred to me as I was racing through my rituals there of pre, during, and post shower.
我是杰森·莫玛，而斯马尔斯正在破我处。Smart Less。杰森，你看起来，你今天怎么看起来这么干净利落？对啊，你看起来真的很不错。因为我洗澡了。我刚洗完澡出来。我很高兴我们今天稍微耽误了一会儿，因为我稍微有点落后。当我在脑海中飞速闪过洗澡前、洗澡中和洗澡后的那些流程时，我突然意识到……
Sure. That my loop has gotten quicker. I'm, you know, the sort of, how long does it take you guys from start to finish? Like, oh, shit, I got to get out the door. I got to get out the door. I got to get dressed, got to get out the door. Are you like a 10 minute, 5 minute, 15 or a half hour? I'm a 5.
当然。我的流程变快了。我，你知道，就那种，你们从头到尾要花多长时间？比如，噢，操，我得出门了。我得出门了。我得穿衣服，得出门了。你们是10分钟、5分钟、15分钟还是半小时那种？我是5分钟。
Yeah, it takes me a long, long time. Does it? Yeah. Yeah, because what we're enjoying right now doesn't just happen. What's you're enjoying right now? Yeah, it takes some work. No, because my hair, it gets super, super, super poofy and big, and it takes forever to just do it so I can walk out the door.
对，我要花很长很长的时间。是吗？对。对，因为我们现在享受的这些可不是凭空出现的。你现在享受的是什么？对，这需要花点功夫。不是的，因为我的头发，它会变得超级、超级、超级蓬松而且很大，光是弄好它就能让我出门就得花好久。
And then so how do you get it down? How do you depoof? Is there a product? Ideally, I have to let it air dry it. Because if I blow dry it, it's like a massive. Yeah, and then it's really humid over the UK. Yeah, it's super humid and I put water in it with the product and then I spray it. It takes a long time.
那你是怎么把它弄服帖的？你怎么给它去蓬松？有什么产品吗？理想情况下，我得让它自然风干。因为如果我用吹风机吹干，就会变得像个大……对，而且英国那边真的很潮湿。对，超级潮湿，我在头发里抹上水和产品，然后喷一喷。这要花很长时间。
Oh, my God. We should post on the website just your ritual just for people who are looking to, you know. And Willie, you just, you're just a five minute. I'm a five and go. Truly, just five minutes. I think so. Get your clothes off, get wet, get dry, get dressed. Yeah, I'm a quick shower person.
哦，天哪。我们应该在网站上发一下你的流程，专门给那些想要……而且威利，你只要，你只需要五分钟。我是那种5分钟搞定就走的人。真的，就五分钟。我觉得吧。脱衣服，弄湿，擦干，穿衣服。对，我是个洗澡很快的人。
I'm a really quick shower person Always have been I'll obviously have those moments We have a longer shower But I'm a really quick I'm gonna kind of in and out Well let's stop there for a second What are those moments
我真的是个洗澡非常快的人，一直都是这样。我当然也有那种时候，我们会洗个比较久的澡。但我真的是个非常快、进出很快的人。好吧，我们在这停一下。那些是什么时候？
Where you're taking a longer shower Is that when you're putting hands on yourself? No. No No I'm not My shower is not my jackshack It's not?
就是你洗澡洗得比较久的时候？那是你在自己动手的时候吗？不是。不是，不是。我的洗澡间不是我的打飞机窝。不是吗？
No that's a separate I told you that's a separate building out back Are we seeing you Are we seeing you in your jackshack right? you might be you might be it's a whisper booth slash jackshack no it's uh shower time is long showers is usually like winter time and you're kind of chilled to the bone um well what about you jay how fast can you do it i'm a i'm a 15 minute all in i can be in the car um oh really well yeah yeah that's from getting undressed showered redressed down the stairs
不，那是另外一个，我跟你说过，那是后面的一栋独立建筑。我们能看到你吗？我们现在能在你的打飞机窝里看到你吗？你可能看得到，你可能看得到。那是隔音亭兼打飞机窝。不是，呃，洗澡时间，洗澡洗得久通常是冬天那种冻得透心凉的时候。嗯，那你是怎么样的，杰，你最快能多久？我，我全部弄完只要15分钟，我就可以上车了。哦，真的吗？好吧，对，对，那是从脱衣服、洗澡、重新穿好衣服、下楼……
out of the door maybe i'm 15 as well i bet you're 15 i might be because i do a lot of other stuff you know, grab me everything, do a little quick moisturize. Yeah, that's another thing. I've done as my products, my products have increased as I've gotten older. I've got creams and ointments and fucking... Oh, so you do have cream. All kinds of shit. This is you creamed.
出门，也许我也是15分钟吧。我敢说你也是15分钟。我可能是，因为我还做很多其他的事，你知道的，把什么都抓上，稍微快速抹个保湿霜。对，那是另一回事。随着年龄的增长，我的产品，我的护肤品变多了。我有各种面霜、药膏和该死的……哦，所以你确实有面霜。各种各样的玩意儿。这就是抹了面霜的你。
Oh, I'm fully hydrated right now. Okay. Yeah, yeah. Check me out. Okay. I mean, if you could smell me too. You do have like a... You've got a little bit of a cute boy haircut right now.
哦，我现在水分完全补足了。好吧。对，对。瞧瞧我。好吧。我是说，如果你能闻到我的气味的话。你确实有一种……你现在顶着一个有点像可爱男孩的发型。
Yeah. Hey, thanks, man. Yeah. Yeah, it looks good. Yeah, it does. It's kind of a little... Don't start. acting boyish.
对。嘿，谢谢你，兄弟。对。对，看起来挺不错的。对，确实不错。有点像那种……别开始。表现得像个男孩似的。
Well, no, no, but after the podcast, if you've got some extra time, maybe. Jesus. Hey, Will, who's your fucking guest today? You seem pretty chipper about this guest. I am. I am. I like our guest. I like our guest a lot. Your guest is not intimidating.
好吧，不，不，不过在播客结束后，如果你有空闲时间的话，也许。天哪。嘿，威利，你今天该死的嘉宾是谁？你对这位嘉宾看起来挺高兴的。我是。我是。我喜欢我们的嘉宾。我非常喜欢我们的嘉宾。你的嘉宾一点也不吓人。
He's already making a lot of noise. Yeah. Jason, you better mind your P's and Q's. Really? Yeah. Why? Because he'll reach through the screen and he'll grab you. Is this a hockey player that could tune me up?
他已经制造了很多噪音了。对，杰森，你最好注意点言行。真的吗？对。为什么？因为他会隔着屏幕伸手把你抓过来。这是一个能把我整服帖的冰球运动员吗？
He's not, but he probably, if he grew up in Canada, you would have been. But he didn't, he grew up in Hawaii. Oh, is that right? Yeah. And, you know, he's done a lot of stuff that we love. Barack Obama. He's done a lot of, he's done a lot of, it's not a terrible guest. Did I get it?
他不是，但他大概，如果他在加拿大长大的话，你就会被整服帖了。但他没有，他在夏威夷长大。哦，是这样吗？对。而且，你知道，他做过很多我们喜欢的事情。巴拉克·奥巴马。他做过很多，他做过很多，这不是个糟糕的嘉宾。我猜到了吗？
Yes, no, you didn't get it. But he's done a ton of movies. This guy's been in, like, so many freaking huge movies. I'm going to say, like, I'm going to try to do it so you can just bury it a little bit. You know, things, like I'm not going to say, the obvious ones, A Lego Part 2 movie He was in. Minecraft movie
是的，不，你没猜到。但他演过超级多的电影。这家伙演过好多好多超级卖座的电影。我要说，呃，我要尽量含蓄一点，好让你稍微猜一下。你知道，有些作品，比如我不会说那些显而易见的，他演过《乐高大电影2》。《我的世界》电影
You know him from Fall Guy You know him from Fast X From the Fast X From the Fast series But you also know him From the Aquaman movies And Zach Snyder's Justice League And he has a new show
你从《特技狂人》里认识他。你从《速度与激情10》里认识他。从《速度与激情10》开始。从《速度与激情》系列。但你也从《海王》电影。和扎克·施奈德的《正义联盟》里认识他。而且他有一个新节目。
This is Jason Maimon Let's just bring him out Apple TV TV Awards Jason Mamma Woo Jason Mamma Got it You can't swing these guys
这是杰森·莫玛。让我们把他请出来。Apple TV奖项。杰森·莫玛。呜。杰森·莫玛。懂了。你们可难不倒这些家伙。
Value me I can guess it What's up? What's up? Look at this guy Jason What is your What's your, babe, we got to go.
重视我。我能猜出来。怎么了？怎么了？看看这家伙，杰森。你的，宝贝，我们得走了。
Come on, get dressed. What's your, I got to get undressed shower and redress. What's your out the door? Do you do what Jason does? You cream on your face? Yeah, he creams on his face. What's me in and out of the door? How quick you got to go?
快点，穿好衣服。你的，我得脱衣服洗澡再重新穿好。你出门要多久？你做跟杰森一样的事吗？你在脸上抹面霜吗？对，他在脸上抹面霜。我进出家门要多久？你得有多快？
How quick if you're dirty and you need to shower and get dressed to go out. Yeah, 10, 15 minutes, easy. That's it. What about when the hair was super long? Arm pits, nuts, ass, and then fucking out of the dough. But the hair, what about when the hair? What about when the hair was super long? That's a beast.
如果你很脏，需要洗个澡然后穿好衣服出门，有多快？对，10、15分钟，轻轻松松。就这样。头发超长的时候呢？咯吱窝、蛋蛋、屁股，然后他妈的出门。但是头发呢？头发超长的时候呢？那是个巨兽。
My hair is super long. It's just... Up and a pony? Yeah, it's just in the back, yeah. I'm not cutting my hair again. No. Never again. Never?
我的头发超级长。它只是……扎成马尾？对，它就在脑后，对。我再也不会剪头发了。不。绝不。绝对不？
I don't want to. Does it take like two hours to drive? Is it about that? To drive my hair? Yeah, it must, right? No. You just take it outside. Yeah.
我不想。开车得花两个小时吗？差不多是这样吗？打理我的头发？对，一定是的吧？不。你把它拿到外面去就行了。对。
When you get out and you just let it air dry, you probably look like an 80s rock, like heavy metal guy, right? Just pool everywhere. I mean, real men's drive. Let's be true. You have to, like, don't you have to, like, don't you, you got to condition that shit and you got to watch out for your split ends and all that. You have to put stuff in your hair, I don't put shit in it, man. You don't.
你出去之后让它自然风干，你看起来可能就像个80年代的摇滚乐手，重金属那种人，对吧？到处都是水。我是说，真男人才开车。说真的。你得，难道你不需要，难道你不需要，你得给那玩意儿做护发素，还得注意分叉什么的。你得在头发里抹点东西，我才不在里面抹狗屎呢，兄弟。你没有。
You walk around with a bunch of hair ties on your wrist. I do, I do. You do, right? I do. Yeah, there is. I do, I do, too, the hair ties, but I just. J.B, you spend a lot of time worried about your split ends? Is this something that keeps you like?
你手腕上戴着一堆发圈到处走。我有，我有。你有的，对吧？我有。对，确实有。我也有，也有发圈，但我只是……J.B，你花很多时间担心你的发尾分叉吗？这是那种会让你……的事吗？
You know, when my hair was long for a second there, I was like, oh, shit, this is a, this is a nightmare. It's not fun. Oh, it's easy. My mom, my mom, do you. really do do you do all the stuff that jason does too with the creams and the things and the and the he's younger than us he doesn't need to yet no no of course i put a cream on my face but my face yeah it feels dry yeah because i mean i feel like there's a lot of chlorine in the water just when you know i'm in london right now and it's like everything so am i you just like yeah you're just like
你知道的，当我的头发留长了一会儿的时候，我在想，哦，操，这简直是个噩梦。一点也不好玩。哦，这很简单。我妈，我妈，你……真的吗？你真的也做杰森做的那些事吗，抹面霜啊各种东西，还有……他比我们年轻，他还不需要呢。不，不，我当然在脸上抹面霜了，但我的脸，对，感觉很干。对，因为我是说，我觉得水里有很多氯，当你，你知道的，我现在在伦敦，这里的一切都……我也是，你只是……对。
sure sure sure um yeah i definitely i definitely what part what part of time i'm just other careful jason i'm at the rosewood right now i was supposed to be in new york but then the flight got canceled oh will here comes will you know i live in the rosewood too get him get him well everyone's getting along come on first question arnette let's go listen hey f you man you just you just completely uh uh you know hijacked him wait is that cold brew up there or is that or is that a logger this is Guinness that's Guinness yeah because it's what it's like 6 p.m. over there go get it yeah it's uh yeah yeah it's six p.
当然，当然，当然，呃，我绝对，我绝对……什么时间，我只是……小心点，杰森，我现在在瑰丽酒店。我本来应该在纽约的，但航班取消了。哦，威利，威利来了。你知道我也住在瑰丽酒店吗？去抓他，去抓他，威利。大家相处得很好，来吧。第一个问题，阿内特，我们开始吧。听着，嘿，去你妈的，兄弟，你刚刚，你刚刚完全，呃，呃，你知道的，把他劫持了。等等，上面那个是冷萃咖啡还是，还是拉格啤酒？这是健力士啤酒。那是健力士。对，因为那是，那边大概下午6点了吧。去拿一杯吧。对，那是，对，对，那是6点……
Are you getting after it tonight? What's going on tonight? No, I'm going to spend the time with my lady. She's in here doing a movie. So my intention was to be, I was supposed to do Fallon tonight. So I was in, I'm in Budapest right now. Yeah, I'm in Budapest shooting Dune. So I flew in, and then we got stuck in a storm,
你今晚打算嗨起来吗？今晚有什么安排？不，我要和我女朋友共度时光。她在这里拍电影。所以我的本意是，我本来今晚要上吉米·法伦的节目。所以我当时在，我现在在布达佩斯。对，我在布达佩斯拍《沙丘》。所以我飞了过去，然后我们被困在风暴里了，
and then I couldn't get in. And so I was supposed to do Fallon. And, but I mean, I can do you guys from there. Now we got stuck doing us. Yeah. No, I fucking, you guys, you guys are popping my chair, you guys. You're the first podcast I've ever done. No way!
然后我就去不成了。所以我本来应该上法伦的节目的。但是，我是说，我可以从那儿连线你们。现在我们被困在做我们自己了。对。不，我他妈的，你们，你们在破我的处，你们。你们是我做过的第一个播客。不会吧！
You're the first podcast I've ever done. I've never agreed to do these because I'm going to get myself in trouble. So please don't get me in trouble. Listen, I, listen, you know this, Jason. The first time that we met was like at some adventure or something. But you're one of those dudes. The first time we met, I felt like I knew you. We freaked the fuck out is what we did.
你是我做过的第一个播客。我从来没答应做这些，因为我会给自己惹麻烦。所以请别给我惹麻烦。听着，我，听着，你知道的，杰森。我们第一次见面是在某个冒险活动还是什么地方。但你就是那种类型的家伙。我们第一次见面的时候，我觉得我就像认识你一样。我们当时都吓坏了，我们就是这样的。
Yeah, we freaked out. Yeah, you were outside smoking. I was like, yeah. Yes. You grab me and wrap me. I was like, oh, shit. I love this. Same thing with Bateman, though.
对，我们吓坏了。对，你当时在外面抽烟。我就觉得，是的。是的。你抓住我并拥抱了我。我当时想，哦，操。我喜欢这样。贝特曼也是这样。
Well, this is the same thing. This is one of the great guys. It was the same thing, man. Yeah. You are a good dude. So, wait, so you had to cancel on Fallon because of whether, I wonder who Fallon calls. Everyone's got like that call. Like, I think, I forget who Kimmel said his call is when a guest drops out last minute.
好吧，这也是一样的。这是个非常棒的家伙。也是这样的，兄弟。你是个好人。所以，等等，所以你因为天气原因不得不取消法伦的节目，我在想法伦会打电话给谁。每个人都有那种备用人选。就像，我想，我忘了吉梅尔说过当有嘉宾最后一分钟取消时他会打给谁。
You've got somebody you can get on the blower to get, hey, can you drive down and do the show tonight? Because, you know, they're live. I wonder who calls. Yeah, well, I mean, it was a pre-tape. So, I mean, it's, I've been, I've had to, I've done it a few times. Yeah, you've been. You've been a call-a-friend? I've last-minute it for Kimmel before, and I've last-
你总得有个人可以打电话，嘿，你能开车过来今晚做节目吗？因为，你知道的，他们是直播。我在想他会打电话给谁。对，好吧，我是说，那是录播。所以，我是说，我曾经，我做过好几次了。对，你做过。你当过“呼叫朋友”的人吗？我以前为吉梅尔救过场，我最后时刻……
You are one of the great all-time talk-show guests. That is true. They'd call them, they'd be like, so-and-so, like their flight got canceled, or they were sick or whatever, and you come and make a jackass out of yourself for 15 minutes. No, you are one of the great all-time talk-show guests. Jay, Mama, how are you, how, do you like the talk shows? I do, I love, yeah.
你是史上最棒的脱口秀嘉宾之一。这是真的。他们会打电话给他们，说，某某某，他们的航班取消了，或者他们生病了什么的，然后你就会去，在15分钟内把自己当成个傻瓜。不，你是史上最棒的脱口秀嘉宾之一。杰，莫玛，你怎么样，你，你喜欢脱口秀吗？我喜欢，我喜欢，对。
I mean, listen, I think this is probably way better to do because it's way more personal and you get time. Well, this is just a conversation. bullshit thing but like you don't have to get out you don't have to dress up and like you just show up yeah you gotta have bits on those talk shows yeah it just depends on what you're supporting like right now I'm doing like my dream project like it's my
我是说，听着，我觉得做这个可能要好得多，因为这更私人化，而且你有时间。好吧，这只是个对话。废话连篇的那种，但你不用出门，你不用盛装打扮，你只要出现就行了。对，你在那些脱口秀上得有段子。对，这只取决于你在宣传什么，比如现在我在做我的梦想项目，就像我的……
brave heart or my dance is wolf so what do I've worked my no no no chief of war so the chief of show that I'm coming out is 1790s Hawaii so I created it oh no way I wrote it no way I directed it and actually it's 90s he did all of this August 1st on Apple TV yeah so directed all the episodes no no
《勇敢的心》或《与狼共舞》，所以我做了我的……不，不，不，酋长战争。所以我要推出的节目是1790年代的夏威夷，是我创作的。哦，不会吧！我写的。不会吧！我导演的。而且实际上是90年代……他完成了所有这一切，8月1st在Apple TV上，对。所以导演了所有集数？不，不。
No, no, no, no, I didn't. I mean, I couldn't. I mean, it couldn't do it all of it. But I mean, I created the show. I co-created it and wrote it with my partner. But it's been like my 10-year project that I did with Apple, and it's all like just right after the white man came. So it's like, it's 1790s Hawaii. Wow. It's all in Alela Hawaii. So it's all in the language, which is, you know, very, it's a, it's a pretty big deal. Whole thing subtitled?
不，不，不，不，我没有。我是说，我不能。我是说，我不可能完成所有这些。但我是说，我创作了这个节目。我和我的搭档共同创作并编写了它。但这就像是我与苹果公司合作了10年的项目，背景正好是白人到来之后。所以就像是1790年代的夏威夷。哇。而且全部是用夏威夷语（ʻŌlelo Hawaiʻi）说的。所以全都是那个语言，你知道的，非常，这是一件相当大的事。整部剧都有字幕吗？
It's a subtitled. But it does, it slowly gets into English. but oh buddy it's my character actually like he he leaves Hawaii and he goes out to the world and he comes back with all the weapons but he basically gets to see the world and just see what's coming and then he unites it's
是有字幕的。但它会慢慢融入英语。但哦，老兄，我的角色实际上，他离开夏威夷去了外面的世界，带着所有的武器回来了，但他基本上是去看世界，去看即将到来的东西，然后他统一了……
it's about the unification of the Hawaiian Islands Sean that's your approach when you're in the UK right just slowly get into English so Jason talk a little bit how did it start what was the genesis of this whole idea of doing this project I mean it's just it's never
这是关于夏威夷群岛的统一。肖恩，你在英国时也是这套策略吧？就是慢慢融入英语。所以杰森，稍微讲讲，这一切是怎么开始的？做这个项目的整个创意起源是什么？我是说，这从来没有……
happened before you know these images um my great great great grandfather has never even seen anything like this so we've only had these in paintings or in museums so nothing has ever existed like this yeah i know nothing about yeah so it's just like wanting to make something about king come mehamehah and just like our people and all the different things that were happening but i needed something that would encompass a lot of things that were going on it's like telling abraham lincoln's story and you're like that's why spielberg did gettysburg you know it's just it's just the little moments of his life but it's like how do I encompass
以前发生过，你知道的，这些影像，我的曾曾曾祖父甚至从未见过这样的东西。所以我们只在画作或博物馆里见过这些。所以以前从来没有存在过这样的东西。对，我对这个一无所知。所以这就像是想创作一些关于卡美哈美哈国王的故事，关于我们的人民以及当时发生的所有不同事情。但我需要一些能够涵盖当时正在发生的大量事情的东西。这就像讲述亚伯拉罕·林肯的故事，你会觉得，这就是斯皮尔伯格拍《葛底斯堡战役》的原因，你知道的，这只是他生活中的微小片刻，但就像我该如何涵盖……
this whole area of Hawaii and this character like helped me do that how was what was what was it was this the settlement the settling of Hawaii like when the white man came over was it was it a
夏威夷的整个这一片区域，以及这个角色如何帮助我做到这一点？夏威夷的定居情况是怎样的？当白人过来的时候，是……
was it like a war was it contentious was it smooth was it I mean I think when I think when Cook first came they were you know kind of blown away and what happened is I think, you know, he left. They kind of snuck onto the ship and maybe took a couple things. And then they executed one of them, I think.
是一场战争吗？充满争议吗？还是顺利的？我是说，我觉得当库克船长第一次来的时候，他们，你知道的，有点被震撼到了，发生的事情是，我想，你知道的，他离开了。他们有点偷偷溜上船，可能拿了几样东西。然后他们处决了其中一个人，我想。
And that pissed everybody off. And so they left. And when they got stuck in a storm, they came back. And that's when all hell broke loose. And so that's when Cook died on the big island. Wait a guy. But, yeah. So when Captain Cook died in Hawaii.
这把所有人都惹毛了。于是他们离开了。当他们被困在风暴中时，他们又回来了。就在那时，彻底乱套了。所以库克就是在夏威夷大岛上死去的。等等，一个家伙。但是，是的。所以当库克船长在夏威夷死后。
Oh. So, but this is after Cook. So, but it's, it's, it's, it's, it's just a really beautiful story. It's very much like an Arthurian kind of, you know, the Guinevere, Sir Lancelot, King Arthur story between, you have this love story at the same time, you have us, a character that leaves Hawaii, he goes to China, he goes to the Philippines, he goes to Alaska, and he comes back, and that's what he brings back all the weapons. And he sees the outside world, and he sees what's coming. Yeah. And you're going to see what's happening in Hawaii at the time. So it's a very huge, huge.
哦。所以，但这发生在库克之后。但是，这是一个非常美丽的故事。非常像亚瑟王那种，桂妮薇儿、兰斯洛特爵士、亚瑟王的故事，你同时拥有一段爱情故事，你有一个离开夏威夷的角色，他去过中国，去过菲律宾，去过阿拉斯加，然后他回来了，这就是他带回武器的地方。他看到了外面的世界，他看到了即将到来的东西。是的。你会看到当时夏威夷正在发生的事情。所以这是一个非常宏大、宏大的节目。
show yeah wow yeah dude it's so cool that's really great as a guy who's coming out on my birthday guys is that right august oh wait happy birthday uh yeah wait so so going to do that and come being being you know uh being Hawaiian and and coming home and doing this story that obviously means a lot to you was it uh i imagine there must have been a bunch of moments you had where it was like almost spiritual or you just like felt like the the fact that you got to do this and tell this story must have been pretty rad. I mean, I don't think there's anything bigger that I'll do because, I mean, it's not like I'm playing a superhero
真的吗？哇，老兄，太酷了，真的太棒了。作为一个在我的生日上映作品的家伙，伙计们，是吗？8月。哦，等等，生日快乐。呃，是的，等等，所以，要去做到这一点，成为，你知道的，夏威夷人，回到家乡，讲述这个显然对你意义重大的故事，是不是，我想一定有很多时刻，你会觉得几乎具有精神上的意义，或者你只是觉得，你能够做到这一点并讲述这个故事，一定非常酷。我是说，我不认为我会做什么更大的事了，因为，我是说，我可不是在演超级英雄……
or something like that. I'm playing my ancestors. I'm actually like, you know, was there pressure in that? Did you feel like kind of, yeah. I mean, like I'm putting on outfits that you're not even allowed to. I mean, they're just in museums. So the things that we're wearing, I wouldn't even be allowed to wear.
或者类似的东西。我在扮演我的祖先。我实际上是在，你知道的。这其中有压力吗？你有没有感觉到，是的。我是说，就像我穿上那些你甚至不允许穿的服装。我是说，它们只存在于博物馆里。所以我们穿的东西，我甚至都不被允许穿。
You know what I mean? Like, so it's, even extras were wearing it. So it was a huge thing. And at the same time, it's like, You know, the movies we had were from, like, El Toro, they're from New Zealand. Like, once we're warriors or, like, whale rider. Like, there's all these Polynesian stories. But there hasn't been something from Hawaii.
你知道我的意思吗？所以，甚至连群演都在穿。所以这是一件大事。与此同时，就像是，你知道的，我们拥有的电影来自，比如，埃尔托罗，来自新西兰。就像《最后的勇士》或《鲸骑士》。有所有这些波利尼西亚的故事。但还没有来自夏威夷的故事。
So it really kind of united Polynesia because there's not really, everyone comes to Hawaii. They make movies there, but they don't make Hawaiian movies. They don't make movies about us. And so, you know, we're a part of America. We just, no one really knows our story. And so I feel like this, this thing is something that's never happened before. And at the same time, we didn't really have the resources. And so it's really united Polynesia because we got Tongin, Samoan, Fijian, Tahitian, Taishin, Māori,
所以它真的某种程度上团结了波利尼西亚，因为其实并没有，每个人都来夏威夷。他们在那里拍电影，但他们不拍夏威夷电影。他们不拍关于我们的电影。所以，你知道的，我们是美国的一部分。只是没有人真正了解我们的故事。所以我觉得这个东西是以前从未发生过的。与此同时，我们其实没有资源。所以它真的团结了波利尼西亚，因为我们有汤加人、萨摩亚人、斐济人、大溪地人、大溪地人、毛利人，
all these different cultures helping us tell this story. So it's been really wonderful. How old were you when you, how long did you grow up before you left? My parents got divorced when I was six months old. So it was pretty shitty. I left at a very young age, but I was raised in Iowa, which is really, when most people think it's great, I think it's really great. I grew up in the Midwest, which is, if you grow up in the Midwest, you kind of know that it's a pretty spectacular place.
所有这些不同的文化都在帮助我们讲述这个故事。所以这真的太棒了。你离开之前，在夏威夷生活了多久？我六个月大时我父母就离婚了。所以这挺操蛋的。我很小的时候就离开了，但我是在爱荷华州长大的，当大多数人觉得这很棒时，我觉得这真的太棒了。我在中西部长大，如果你在中西部长大，你就会知道那是一个相当壮观的地方。
You grow up with, like, I agree. I mean, my work ethic, family values, like, it's a very strong place. Having said that I grew up where Bridges of Madison County was made. So I grew up literally, like, not a race. So I'd go from literally a small country town to going to, like, kind of the reservation of the Hawaiian side. It's a whole, basically where I'm from is all local side. And it's not really being accepted there or being accepted there. So it was a bit of a, it's a bit of like trying to figure that out.
你和……我完全同意。我是说，我的职业道德，家庭价值观，这是一个非常强大地方。话虽如此，我是在拍摄《廊桥遗梦》的地方长大的。所以我literally是在，就像，不是一个种族。所以我从一个小乡村直接去到了夏威夷人保留地那种地方。基本上我来自的地方都是本地人的一侧。在那里不被接受，或者在这里不被接受。所以这有点像，有点像去弄清楚这一切。
But I would spend my summers with my father. And, you know, and then I would, you know, go to school with my mother. So you were born in Hawaii, then went to Iowa, then went back to Hawaii? Yeah. So when I was in college, I went out to Colorado and that's where I was going. And then I kind of, my family, I come from one of the biggest serve families. in Hawaii. My great uncles
但我夏天会和父亲一起过。然后，你知道的，我会和母亲一起上学。所以你是出生在夏威夷，然后去爱荷华州，然后又回到夏威夷？对。所以当我上大学时，我去了科罗拉多州，那是我当时要去的地方。然后我有点，我的家人，我来自夏威夷最大的冲浪世家之一。我的伯公们……
like Buffalo Kualana. I come from a long list of amazing watermen. So I kind of went over there to like really sink in with my family, get to know my father better. And I was 19. And then a TV show came and I ended up,
就像水牛库阿拉纳（Buffalo Keaulana）。我来自一个伟大的水人家族。所以我去那里是为了真正融入我的家族，更好地了解我的父亲。我当时19岁。然后一个电视节目找到了我，我最终……
I was just folding t-shirts at the family surf shop and then I ended up getting a lead role in this really horrible show that just fucking killed me. But I found acting. You know what I'm talking about, baby. Yeah, yeah.
我当时只是在家族冲浪店里叠T恤，然后我最终在这个该死的让我痛苦万分的糟糕节目里得到了主角。但我找到了表演。你知道我在说什么，宝贝。对，对。
Right. So you're working in a surf shop. All the fucking holes we've got to dig ourselves. That's right. Were you, what were you doing? So in Hawaii, so you're working at the family surf shop. Were you surfing? How did you, did you get on a board?
没错。所以你在冲浪店工作。所有我们得自己挖的坑。没错。你当时在做什么？所以在夏威夷，你在家族冲浪店工作。你在冲浪吗？你是怎么，你踩上冲浪板了吗？
Yeah, yeah. I was torn in big waves. Like this movie came out called In God's Hands. And my cousin, Brian Kilana, he was the one who was towing in with Laird and all and stuff. And so I was like, what am I doing? I can go surf these big ways of my family. So I took the summer off and I went over there.
对，对。我在巨浪中冲浪。有部电影叫《上帝之手》上映了。我的表弟布莱恩·库阿拉纳（Brian Keaulana），他就是那个和莱尔德（Laird）一起用拖曳冲浪的人。所以我在想，我在干什么？我可以和我的家人一起去冲浪这些大浪。所以我请了暑假，去了那里。
And then the moment I was supposed to go back to school, I got the lead role, so I was just like, it was... Wait, wait, on the surfing part, did you... Have you been towed into waves? Like, do you surf those? Come on. Yeah, yeah. I towed in like a 20-foot wave with, uh, out in McCool. Unleaders.
然后就在我本该回学校的那天，我得到了主角，所以我当时就觉得，这……等等，等等，关于冲浪那部分，你……你尝试过拖曳冲浪吗？比如你冲过那些浪吗？拜托。对，对。我和莱尔德在麦库（McCool）冲过20英尺的浪。Unleaders。
This is a real man, you guys. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I mean, I actually drowned in Laird's... You got once towed to the service stage, to the BMW stage, didn't you?
伙计们，这才是真男人。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我是说，我实际上在莱尔德的……你曾经被拖到服务台，拖到宝马服务台，对吧？
They towed you. Yeah, well, actually, it's only on a flatbed. My car, because of the front faring, you couldn't tow it, so you got to put it. on a flatbed but um i did ride up front with the guy yeah no way up front with the guy wait mama tell me wait you almost drowned for real yeah i uh i was doing this paddle we we we we went in at jaws oh my god josh is the real deal and we and we we did like a 14th it's made it's like a 13 mile paddle with uh from i was with dave kalama my friend joe flanagan and uh and uh larat hamilton we paddle like 13 miles down the coast
他们拖着你。对，其实那只是在平板拖车上。我的车，因为前导流板，你没法拖它，所以你得把它放在平板拖车上。但，呃，我的确坐在那个家伙的前面，对，没错，坐在那个家伙前面。等等，莫玛，告诉我，等等，你差一点淹死，真的吗？对，我，我当时在做这个划桨，我们，我们，我们在大白鲨（Jaws）下水。天哪，大白鲨来真的，我们，我们做了大概14英里，就像13英里的划桨，我当时和我的朋友大卫·卡拉玛（Dave Kalama）、乔·弗拉纳根（Joe Flanagan）以及莱尔德·汉密尔顿（Laird Hamilton）在一起，我们沿着海岸划了大概13英里。
and you're kind of almost a mile offshore and then my leash snapped and I was about we're about seven miles into it and my leash snapped and the it's so windy on Maui and so the board just went I couldn't even see it anymore Sean you were going to say your leash snapped
你离岸边差不多有一英里远，然后我的脚绳断了。我们大概划了七英里左右，我的脚绳断了，毛伊岛的风太大了，所以冲浪板一下子就，我甚至都看不到它了。肖恩，你本来想说你的脚绳也断过一次对吧，但很酷的是你不用付钱给那家伙，因为如果你把它扯得那么猛，它肯定会断。我告诉你，我知道，你知道我做了什么吗，结果最后是免费的，别把它扯得那么猛，它他妈的会断的。
once too but it was cool because you didn't have to pay the guy right because it's like you snap it that hard on me it's going to break I told you I know and you know what I did that on it ended up being free don't yank on it so hard it'll fucking break.
然后我们20年后结婚了。嘿，听着，杰森。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。等等，告诉我，当你处于那种快要淹死的状态时，你的大脑是什么样的？对，太可怕了。所以你知道发生了什么。你在那一刻有应对的方案吗？
And then we ended up getting married 20 years later. Hey, listen, Jason. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show. Wait, so tell me, when you're in that position of almost drowning, what is your brain like? Yeah, it's so scary. So you know what's happening. Do you have a protocol of what to do in that moment?
你的脑子还能清醒到知道怎么自救吗？对，对。我是说，我受过很好的训练。而且当时情况还行，所以我只是，我挨了好几个闷棍。那些浪挺大的，大概有10英尺，10英尺高的夏威夷巨浪，但我当时离岸边literally大概有半英里远，而且我，这个地方实际上叫“狗屎操蛋湾（shit fucks）”，字面意思，因为有所有的回卷水流，而且周四有美元特饮。
Are you even thinking clearly enough to know how to save yourself? Yeah, yeah. I mean, I was trained pretty well. Also, it was fine, so I was just, I took quite a few on the head. They're pretty big, like 10 foot, 10 foot Hawaiian waves, but I'm literally probably a half mile at that point offshore, and it was just, I was, it's actually this place is called shit fucks, and it's literally because there's all this water that pulls out and there's a dollar drinks on Thursdays.
它会把你往外拽，然后你就会被这些巨浪击中。所以我被困在这个疯狂的地方，可能是一个小时。外礁。而且我不知道的是，我真的在哪个外礁上，他们看不到我，我拿着桨挥舞着，他们看不到我，浪太大了，大得几乎把我的裤子都冲掉了。等等。我伸手把裤子穿了回去。裤子在狗屎操蛋湾掉了。
And it just, it just, it pulls you out and you just get hit with these waves. So I was stuck in this crazy spot, which is probably the hour. Reef and unknown to me, I was really on the Outer Reef and they couldn't see me and I had my paddle and I was waving it and they couldn't see me and the ways were so big it was basically took my shorts off it was so fucking big. Hang on. I reached down, put the shorts back on. Shorts off at shit fucks.
我确信那在村子里。裤子在狗屎操蛋湾掉了。我往里看。我往里看，当时我就想，我女儿那时才三个月大，然后，我，我崩溃了。我当时想，哦，天哪。我不能……最后是谁救了你？
I'm pretty sure that's in the village. Shorts were off at shit fucks. I looked in. I looked in and I was just like my daughter at that time was three months old and, uh, I was, I just, I lost it. I was like, oh, God. I couldn't. And who ended up saving you?
对，对，对。最后发生的事情是，我在那待了一会儿。然后我，我就是看不到任何人来接我。而且我再也动不了了。我的胳膊和腿在我待了一会儿之后就放弃了。但莱尔德不得不进去，绕过我，从我后面划过来。所以，就像是沿着海岸划桨。所以它是顺着信风的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, what ended up happened, I was out there for a while. And then I, I just couldn't see anyone coming to get me. And I couldn't move anymore. And my arms and my legs gave up after, you know, I was out there for a while. But Laird had to go in and then go all the way around me and paddle up behind me. So, like, it's a coastal paddle. So it goes with the trade winds.
所以你顺着海岸向下。然后他从后面过来，而我已经放弃了。我的身体停摆了。就像，我的胳膊再也动不了了。我沉了下去。然后我的脚趾碰到了外礁。就像，我literally放弃了。我在心里尖叫。
So you're going down the coast. And then he came from behind, and I had already given up. My body stopped. Like, I couldn't move my arms anymore. And I bubbled down. And then my toe hit the outer reef. Like, I literally gave up. And I'm screaming inside.
然后我的脚刚好碰到了外礁。我不知道那是一头该死的鲸鱼还是只是一块石头。但我只是伸手下去，抓住它。我跳了起来。我被另一个浪击中，我把双脚插进珊瑚里，我literally就在海洋中央，我甚至勉强能让嘴唇露出水面。
And my foot just hits the outer reef. And I don't know if it was a fucking whale or, like, just could be one rock. But I just reached down, grab it. I jump up. I get hit by another wave. and I dig my feet into the coral and I'm literally in the middle of the ocean and I'm just, I could barely
只是为了呼吸和喘口气，但我已经放弃了，所以这就像是你已经放弃并死过一次，然后得到了第二次机会。然后我在那又待了大概10分钟，我抓着这块礁石的边缘，然后我听到莱尔德从后面过来，他带着我的板，拖着他的板，我上了板，他说，你没事吧，我说，不。
put my lips above. It's just to breathe and get a break but I had already given up so it's like you've already given up and died and have the second chance at it and then I still stayed out there for like 10 minutes and I was hanging on the side of this reef and then I hear Laird come from behind
我重新上了板，我们开始划桨，他说，你得往外划，往外划，所以我们继续往外划，我一直在努力冲过每一个浪。我丢了板，他丢了板，那狗屎地方真是残酷，从那个地方撤出来太难了。所以我们最终在很远的地方撤了出来，差不多在毛伊岛的架子上。
and he's on my board, towing his board and I get on and he's like, you're right and I'm like, no. I get back on the board and we start paddling he's like you got to go out out and so we just keep paddling out and I just keep trying to go over every wave
我还有七英里的路要划，我的脚上全是血，我 literalmente 就像我的祖先一样，低着头一路划回来，我们终于上岸了。我是说，我当时可能会被……
I lose the board he loses the board it's just the shit fucking it is brutal getting out of the spot and so we end up getting out really far on the end like pretty much on the shelf of Maui
到处都是鲨鱼，但我 literally 就像是在整条该死的海岸线上拖行。板上全是血。你身上还在滴着血。我们上岸了，那就是，我以前抽烟。我以前抽烟，一天抽两三包。我自己卷烟草。为了我的孩子，我戒不掉。
and I have seven more miles to paddle my feet are covering blood and I'm just literally like my ancestors just paddling the rest of this way head down and we get out And I mean, I could have been trolling.
为了我的前妻，戒不掉。我戒不掉烟。而当我从水里出来的那一刻，我再也没有抽过烟。就像，我死过一次。我只是死过一次。就像，我试了又试，但我再也没法抽了，因为我放弃了。就像，我放弃了我的生命。
There could be sharks everywhere, but I'm just, like, trolling this whole fucking coast. Bloods all over the board. All this blood you're dropping, too. And we get in, and that's, I used to smoke. And I used to smoke, like, two, three packs a day. I'd roll the pouch. I couldn't stop for my kids.
你还记得你觉得自己得救了的那一刻吗？你觉得，他真的，你真的挺过来了的那一刻？你还记得那个时刻吗？我记得看到他，但我当时在想，但是，你知道的，我已经死了10分钟了，你知道吗？如果没有外礁的话，那就得是10分钟。如果没有外礁，如果没有一些，你知道的，而且我相信我的祖先。我相信我的，你知道的，我向我的奶奶和爷爷祈祷。我是说，我当时在拼死挣扎。而且我处境糟糕。
Couldn't stop for my ex. I couldn't stop smoking. And the moment I came out, I never smoked again. Like, I just died. I just died. Like, I tried and tried, but I couldn't do it again because I just, I gave up. Like, I gave up my life.
你被困在那种巨浪中的那种地方。没有冲浪板。你就死定了。根本没有办法游回来。根本没有。我没有那个能力。所以那是个很糟糕的处境。但我猜这给你带来了，这是一个相当强烈的对比，并给你提供了一些人生视角，就像你说的，你戒烟了。
Do you remember the moment you felt that you were saved, that you, that he actually, that you actually got through it? Do you remember that moment? I remember seeing him, but I was like, but, you know, I was 10 minutes dead already, you know? That would have been 10 minutes. Had there not been the outer reef, like, had there not been some, you know, and I do believe my answers. I do believe my, you know, I prayed to my grandmother and my grandfather. I mean, I was, I was reaching. And I was in a bad position.
而且从那一刻起，你就会想，好吧，我经历过一些操蛋的事，其他所有事情都算是白捡的。你当时有没有一点这种感觉？你知道，我经历了一段更艰难的时期。我想，你知道的，我有一些特质，我不知道。那天晚上我对自己的要求挺严苛的。我讨厌那些愚蠢的破事。我真的真的很生自己的气，气愤自己陷入那样的境地，而且可能因为自己做过的那些蠢事而更加折磨自己。
And you're stuck out there in that kind of way. It's no bored. You're fucked. And there's no way to swim in. It's just not. I don't have that. So it was a bad spot to be in. But I imagine that gives you like a, it's a pretty sharp contrast and gives you some perspective to, like you said, you quit smoking.
所以我不知道。那是一个有点艰难的学习曲线，但我感觉我一直都是这样。我的学习曲线对我很严苛，所以。我前几天还在想这个，关于我是如何发现自己过着一种完全不同于20多岁时的生活。我是说，正如每个人都会经历的那样，你会经历这些阶段，你现在是如何看待自己的生活的，作为一个功能健全的……
And that going forward from that moment, you're like, all right, I've been through some shit and everything else is kind of gravy. Did you have a little bit of that? You know, I did a little harder run. I think, you know, I have qualities that are, I don't know. I was pretty hard on myself that night. I didn't love a stupid shit. And I just really was, like, pissed on myself for the position I was in and probably tortured myself even more for the stupid shit that I did.
你知道的，能够写作、导演、制作、主演的专业人士，并且像，你知道的，参加所有这些成年人的会议，以及所有这些乱七八糟的事情，听起来你早期的疯狂生活中根本没有做过这些，就像我一样，只是个混蛋。我觉得如果你有，是的，我觉得有一种潜质，你身上有那种需要释放的东西，直到我遇到那些真正让我，直到我遇到我的搭档，是的，我遇到了那些真正让我把那些东西释放出来的人，我之前一直在用毒瘾和药物虐待自己，我当时想，是的，但这只是一个你正在燃烧的必经阶段。对，你经历了那个阶段，你必须把它发泄出来，对，对。
So I don't know. It was a bit of a hard learning curve, but I feel like I've always had that. My learning curves are pretty hard on me, so. You know, I was thinking about that the other day about how, you know, I find myself in a completely different life. than I was having in my in my 20s I mean as as everyone does you sort of you go through these stages and how how are you how are you finding your life now as a fully functioning
因为现在可不是干这个的好时机。所以听起来我们在你们本该做这种事的年纪做了那些事。但你把它做得很好，以至于你现在能把这个也做好。你喜欢这样吗？你是否有那种清晰的思路和人生视角？就像那是杰森·莫玛的一个版本。而现在这是杰森的一个版本。它们都是我。
um you know professional that's able to write and direct and produce and star and and like you know take all these sort of adult meetings and like all this kind of shit that it doesn't sound like you were doing at all in in in your in your earlier sexual life like like like me too just being a you know a dickhead i think if you have yeah i think there's a potential that you you you have that needs to come out and i just until i met the people that actually like until i met my partners yeah i met the people that actually made me get those things out i was just bashing myself with addiction and drugs and i'm like yeah but a necessary stage that you're just burning yeah you go through that stage you've got to get it out yeah yeah
我只是在经历这一切。百分之百。是的。我是说，它们都很棒。它们都很棒。我们年轻时做过的一切。我很庆幸，你知道的，这不是唾手可得的，我走到今天这一步经历了一条非常艰难的路。所以，是的，话虽如此，我，我过去差不多12年里一直在导演，我喜欢那个过程，我喜欢制片，我喜欢不只是当一个演员。我喜欢能够，如果有人要对我的作品评头论足，我做出了这个选择，我做出了所有这些选择，当然，比起仅仅当个演员，这感觉很好。去房车里当个演员固然好，但我也喜欢，我是说这就是我的大脑运转的方式，我想同时有一百件事情在进行，是的，我要当个演员。我只是热爱工作。
Because now's not a good time to do it. So it sounds like we were doing that stuff at a time when you're supposed to. But you do that really well such that you can now do this really well. And are you enjoying that? And do you have that kind of clarity and perspective? Like that was a version of Jason Mamoa. And now this is a version of Jason. And they're both me.
我热爱，我就是喜欢为那些事情负责。好吧，你也因此而感激所有的一切，杰森，就像你刚刚说的。而且我觉得我正在发现，我现在这个年纪正在经历这个。我55岁了。抱歉，我刚才在等你们说“不会吧”。哦，是的。抱歉。有延迟。
And I'm just going through it. 100%. Yeah. I mean, they're great. They're great. All the things that we did when we were younger. I'm glad I you know it wasn't handed out it was a very hard road to get where I'm at so yeah having said I've been you know I've been directing for last almost 12 years now I like that process I love producing I love not being just an actor I love being able to if someone's going to judge me on something like I took this choice I made all these choices sure instead of just being an actor it's nice just to go to the trailer and be an actor but I also love I mean this is the way my brain works I want to have a hundred things going on yeah and I'm going to be an actor I And I just love working.
有延迟。而且，你知道的，我最近，真的，就过去，我不知道，差不多几周里，我终于有了这样一个时刻，当时我在想，我感觉到这种转变正在发生，这种乌云正在散去，我生活中的这种事情正在发生，让我觉得我挺好的，我能接受今天的自己了。
I love, I just love being responsible for those things. Well, you also appreciate it because of all the things, Jason, like you were just saying. And I think I'm finding, I'm going through it right now at this age. I'm 55. Sorry, I was waiting for you guys to go, no way. Oh, yeah. Sorry. It's a delayed.
这花了我经历了很多不同的狗屎事，它与我生命中的任何其他时期都不同。这真的很酷，非常深远。这是变老带来的礼物之一，对吧？对，没错。你开始不那么在乎别人怎么看你，不那么在乎那些虚伪的做作，不那么费尽心思去说服别人你可能是X、Y或Z。
There's a delay. And, you know, I've just recently, truly, the last, I don't know, almost a couple weeks, I finally had this moment where I was like, I feel this kind of shift happening and this sort of cloud lifting and this thing happening in my life where I feel like I'm okay, I'm cool with who I am today.
这就好比，不，我就是A、B或C。你知道的，我就是我。如果你看得到，那很好。如果你看不到，也没关系。最重要的是，第一号人物明白第一号人物是谁，而且我对这一点感到坦然。世界上只有一个我。我希望你们能喜欢。如果不喜欢，还有其他人可以去交流。
And it took me going through a lot of different shit and it's different from any other period of my life. It's really, it's really rad and really profound. It's one of the gifts of getting older, right? Right, yeah. You start to care a little less about what other people perceive you as, and the artifice and the efforts you make to sort of convince those that you might be X, Y, or Z.
有点像。对，完全是这样。我觉得这其中蕴含着真理。呃，所以莫玛，你刚才说你拍了那个糟糕的节目，但就像，呃，呃，我猜那是你的第一份表演工作吧，对吧，你说的你在夏威夷拍的那个。你知道这有什么酷的吗？我是说，听着，我爱上了表演，因为我以前是个生物专业学生，是个理科生，那是……
And it's like, no, I'm just A, B, or C. You know, like, this is just me. And if you see it, great. If you don't, that's okay, too. It's more, most important is that number one understands who number one is and that I'm okay with that. There's only one of me. And I hope you guys dig it. If you don't, there's other people to talk to.
就像是，不，我只是A、B或C。你知道的，这只是我。如果你看得到，那很好。如果看不到，也没关系。最重要的是，第一重要的就是了解自己是谁，并且我能接受这样的自己。世界上只有一个我。我希望你们会喜欢。如果不喜欢，还有其他人可以去交流。
A little bit. Yeah, totally. I think there's truth in that. um wait so momo you're talking about you did this shitty show but like uh uh you're first i guess that was your first acting gig right the thing you're talking about that you did in white you know what you was kind of cool about i mean like listen i fell in love with acting because i was a i was a biology major i was a science major and that's
有一点吧。是的，完全如此。我觉得这其中有道理。呃，等等，所以Momo你在说你演了那个糟糕的节目，但呃，呃，你首先，我猜那是你的第一份表演工作吧？你刚才说的那件事，你演的那个……你知道吗，我觉得挺酷的一点是，我是说，听着，我爱上表演是因为我以前是个生物学专业的，我曾是个理科生，那是
what i wanted to do and so i um you know baywatch hawaii came and whatever i was 19 years old you got to make a hundred dollars being a extra and i was folding t-shirts for 60 and you got to meet a bunch of hot chicks and I was 19 years old and like yeah okay I'm gonna go on perfect yeah I was like 1300 people showed up down there and we went in and I ended up you know ended up getting the lead role I was supposed to go back to college and my mom's like what are you doing I'm like I don't want to watch why and she's like what I mean like you just you know I didn't know what's cool thing about it and but I fell in love with acting I basically watched tons of movies and every movie I'd watch I just play that character in the next day you know if I
我想做的事，然后呢，你知道的，海滩游侠夏威夷版来了，不管怎样，我当时19岁，做群演一天能赚一百块，而我之前叠T恤一小时才六十，还能认识一群辣妹，我当时19岁，就觉得，好吧，我去。没错，当时有1300个人去了现场，我们进去了，最后我竟然拿到了男主角。我本该回大学的，我妈就问我在干嘛，我说我不想去海滩游侠，她说你在说什么，我的意思是，你才刚刚，你知道的，我当时不知道这有多酷，但我爱上了表演。基本上我看了无数的电影，我看的每一部电影，第二天我就会模仿那个角色的状态，你知道的，如果我
watched fifth element I was Gary Oldman that day I thought if I watched fight clubs I was fucking Tyler Darden in that episode. And so, I mean, I literally just, it was practice and doing all that. And I just didn't give a shit. And I, I, but I fell in love with it. And having said that, every grip and like from catering to the grip, makeup, everyone, they're on my show, you know, I'm 47, 47, 46 on August 1st. And they're all did Chief of War with me. Wow.
看了第五元素，那天我就是加里·奥德曼，我觉得，如果我看了搏击俱乐部，那一集里我他妈就是泰勒·德顿。所以，我的意思是，我真的就是靠练习和做所有这些。而且我根本不在乎。然后我，我，但我爱上了它。话虽如此，从餐饮到灯光、化妆，每个人，他们都在我的剧组里，你知道的，我47岁了，47岁，8月1日就46岁了。他们都和我一起拍了《战争酋长》。哇。
And I'm coming home telling our people's movie. and, you know, I've dug myself out of massive, massive holes. Like, you know, I learned my, I went through college doing, you know, Stargate Atlantis and hiding in Canada and making a sci-fi show. But I learned how to do everything. I was like, listen, I'm going to shoot this myself. So I started at that point when I could write, direct, do all the stuff on my own because I was like 22 episodes, nine months of my life. Yeah. You know, it's just like banging out stuff.
而且我回家还会告诉别人拍电影的事。而且，你知道的，我把自己从巨大、巨大的深渊中拉了出来。就像，你知道的，我吸取了教训，我在大学期间一边拍着《星际之门：亚特兰蒂斯》，躲在加拿大制作一部科幻剧。但我学会了如何做所有事情。我就想，听着，我要自己拍这个。所以我从那时起就开始学习，当我可以自己编剧、导演、做所有这些事情的时候，因为我拍了22集，经历了人生中的九个月。是的。你知道的，这就像是疯狂产出。
And you're like, no, that was my college. And then I had an accident and took some time off. but I, you know, got married, had some kids, and then Game of Thrones came out, and then no one knew what the fuck to do with that guy. Right, right, right, right. You're kind of stuck in that jail of, like, until you get to the fourth season of it.
你会觉得，不，那就是我的大学。然后我出了事故，休息了一段时间。但我呢，你知道的，结婚了，有了几个孩子，然后《权力的游戏》播出了，接着没人知道他妈的该怎么安排这个家伙。对，对，对，对。你有点被困在那样的牢笼里，直到你拍到第四季。
And I was like, while we did Game of Thrones, I did, I wrote, you know, co-wrote my first movie, and I did road to Paloma. And I was just like, fuck this. I made Pride of Gypsies, which is a bunch of actors, a group of friends, and we just made movies together.
我想，在我们拍《权力的游戏》的同时，我写了，你知道的，联合编剧了我的第一部电影，我还拍了《帕洛马之路》。我当时就想，去他妈的。我创立了“吉普赛人骄傲”，那是一群演员，一群朋友，我们就在一起拍电影。
And, you know, some of us were, we'd all hold the boom. We'd all do this. We'd all shoot. And so we all came, from that thing where it's just we did the work we edited it we shot it and that's how we kind of built you know i'm not going to wait for anything so we just kind of went about it that way because i was like no one's going to give me this shit you got to go you got to go get it so we wrote all our own
而且，你知道的，我们有些人，我们会一起扛收音杆。我们会一起做这些。我们都会拍摄。所以我们都是从那种环境中走出来的，我们自己干活、剪辑、拍摄，我们就是这样建立起，你知道的，我不会坐等任何机会，所以我们就用这种方式去做了，因为我觉得没有人会把这些施舍给你，你必须去争取，你必须去把它夺过来，所以我们编写了所有自己的
stuff yeah yeah that's cool you know i remember seeing you in game of thrones and i was like you just you're the character and the size of you i was just like my god this guy's such an an incredibly, you know, fit human being and the size of it, I was like, and then on, because your entrance, you're like, oh, my God, who's this guy? And then you start acting, you're like, oh, wow, he's like a brilliant actor.
东西。是的，是的，太酷了，你知道的，我记得在《权力的游戏》里看到你，当时我就觉得，你就是那个角色，你的体型，我当时就想，天哪，这家伙简直是一个不可思议的、你知道的，身材极佳的人类，还有他的体型，我当时就想，然后，因为你的出场，你会想，天哪，这家伙是谁？然后你开始表演，你会觉得，哦，天哪，他就像一个出色的演员。
And you have presence. He has such, you have such presence, apart from your physical, you just have presence as a person that's really magnetic. And I wonder, right, Sean? Like, like, yeah, I was just so surprised that, like, that, I know what you mean by,
而且你很有气场。他有那种，你很有气场，除了你的外表，你整个人就有一种非常吸引人的气场。我在想，对吧，肖恩？就像，就像，是的，我当时太惊讶了，像，我懂你的意思，
well, what do we do with this guy? I was like, well, he's a great actor. That's what you do with him. You just plug him into any role. Was Game of Thrones, was that the first, was that a turning point? It must have been a turning point. That was the turning point.
好吧，我们该拿这家伙怎么办？我当时想，好吧，他是个伟大的演员。这就是你对他做的事。你把他塞进任何角色里就行了。《权力的游戏》，那是第一次吗？那是一个转折点吗？那一定是个转折点。那就是转折点。
You got to respect. But it was, it didn't, like, because he didn't say much, and even though I played, like, a really good character played it and did my job well, but it was, I mean, it's a thing where it's like, I'm a huge SNL fan.
你必须尊重。但它并没有，就像，因为它没有说太多台词，尽管我扮演了一个，一个非常好的角色，演好了它并做好了我的工作，但我的意思是，这是一个这样的事情，我是周六夜现场的超级粉丝。
Like, I love comedy. I just wanted to do comedy. That was the thing I grew up with SNL. It's all I wanted to do. Yeah, yeah, same. And you hosted twice? No one fucking knows me that way, so I didn't know. They just, you know, and they just use me as action or I don't say much.
就像，我热爱喜剧。我只是想演喜剧。那是伴随着周六夜现场长大的东西。那是我唯一想做的事。对，对，一样。你主持过两次？没人他妈的用那种眼光认识我，所以我不知道。他们只是，你知道的，他们只是把我当成动作演员，或者我不怎么说话。
And so it's a very weird thing to kind of live in that action and you're this and that. Because my mom and my dad are both painters, right? My mom, you know, I was raised watching rear window and like gone with the wind and Streetcar Name Desire. I was raised as a single mother that worked four jobs in Iowa. So it's like I didn't grow up, even like grew up into this body. I'm like, I'm a total, like an art nerd. I grew up in a different way. You just kind of like, this isn't really me.
所以那种生活在动作片和你是这样那样的人设中的感觉非常奇怪。因为我爸妈都是画家，对吧？我妈，你知道的，我是看着《后窗》、《乱世佳人》和《欲望号街车》长大的。我是在爱荷华州由一个打四份工的单亲母亲抚养长大的。所以这就像我没有长大，甚至没有长成这样的身材。我心想，我完全是个艺术宅。我的成长经历完全不同。你就会觉得，这其实不是真正的我。
This is more of me. Right, it's difficult. It's like you're this huge presence. You're in this, you're in this big, beautiful God frame. You're a very good looking man too. And inside of that is somebody who not only wants to do comedy, but can also do very subtle, nuanced, dramatic acting as well. And so how do you like, you, like,
这才是更真实的我。没错，这很难。就好像你有着如此庞大的气场。你处在这样一个巨大、美丽的上帝骨架里。你也是个长相非常英俊的男人。而在那副外表里面，藏着一个不仅想演喜剧，而且还能演非常有层次、细腻的戏剧表演的人。所以你该怎么，你喜欢，
you know you obviously have to account for how you come across and so they can only put you in those types of characters and those characters aren't historically super funny or super sensitive you know so it's like i just i mean until you get to know me and like i think we've had a little bit of time with each other some of us but it's like i just you know it's my first time doing a comedy doing doing minecraft finally with jack black and i'm like jesus christ finally i'm like or just getting into s andl like that's that's all that matters to me like just all I would do. You killed it on SNL back.
你知道的，你显然必须考虑到你给人的第一印象，所以他们只能把你放在那种类型的角色里，而那些角色在历史上通常不是超级搞笑或超级敏感的，你知道的，所以这就变成，我的意思是，直到你真正了解我，就像我想我们彼此花了一点时间了解对方一样，但这就变成，你知道的，这是我第一次演喜剧，终于和杰克·布莱克一起拍了《我的世界》，我当时想，天哪，终于了，我心想，或者终于上了周六夜现场，那就是，那才是我唯一在乎的事，就像我唯一想做的事。你在周六夜现场表现太棒了。
Yeah. So funny. Yeah, now you've got the juice where I'm sure you can go to your team and say, hey, so I'd like to do parts like X, Y, or Z. Can you go out there and see... Or create, by the way. I mean, like you created...
太搞笑了。是啊，现在你有了资本，我确信你可以去找你的团队说，嘿，所以我想演X、Y或Z这样的角色。你们能出去看看……或者自己创作，顺便说一句。我的意思是，就像你创作了……
Well, you're busy doing your job, they can do theirs trying to bring you options in those areas because you've got the juice to... Where, like, a part is written not for a guy with your physical type, but you've got enough juice now where they can actually change what that actor might be,
好吧，当你忙着做你的工作时，他们可以做他们的工作，试图在这些领域为你带来选择，因为你有资本去……在这些领域，比如一个角色不是为你这种体型的硬汉写的，但你现在有足够的资本，他们实际上可以改变那个演员可能会是怎样的，
what that character might look like without changing any of the dialogue, you know? Yeah. Yeah, you should tell. Yes, he agrees with you. But, yes, they can search it out, but I wonder, do you have like, because you mentioned Rhodes Plum and the movie
那个角色可能会是什么样子，而不需要改变任何台词，你知道吗？对。是的，你应该告诉。是的，他同意你的观点。但是，是的，他们可以去寻找，不过我在想，你有没有，因为你提到了《帕洛马之路》和那部
that you wrote and directed, which... What was... By the way, when you first started directing, and this is a Jason question, did you love that shift to directing? I love it. I mean, I don't want to actually be in front. I'd rather be behind the camera.
你编剧并导演的电影，那是……顺便问一下，当你刚开始当导演时——这是一个关于杰森的问题——你喜欢向导演的转变吗？我太喜欢了。我的意思是，我其实不想站在镜头前。我宁愿待在摄像机后面。
Like, I love every... You're like J.B. J.B. is the same. Yeah, I mean, like, that's where it's at. I mean, there's top and bottom jokes there. You say you don't want to be in front, you want to be in the... But I don't have it fully written right now, but you can just come back to me on that. Check your text.
就像，我喜欢每一个……你就像J.B.一样。J.B.也是一样。对，我的意思是，这才是精髓所在。我的意思是，那里有各种各样的笑话。你说你不想站在镜头前，你想在……但我现在还没完全写好，不过你可以回头再找我谈这个。查收你的短信。
Check your text. Working the check. I mean, you love being behind the camera, right? Oh, God. Yeah, I would stay back there and never, never act again. Although I do like acting, and I also... Acting in something that I'm directing, I really love just because, as you said, I love being overwhelmed with the amount of work and responsibility as opposed to just hiding in the trailer. You know, like, I'm a glutton for that stuff.
查收你的短信。干查收这活。我的意思是，你喜欢待在摄像机后面，对吧？天哪。是的，我会待在后面，再也不演戏了。虽然我确实喜欢演戏，而且我也……在我导演的作品里演戏，我真的非常喜欢，因为正如你所说，我喜欢被大量的工作和责任压得喘不过气来的感觉，而不是只躲在保姆车里。你知道的，就像，我就是个自讨苦吃的家伙。
But you drop it in, like, on smoking aces and shit like that. Yeah, that's hilarious. Like, you got to, like, that stuff is like, you know, when you have little roles that come in, you're like, I want to support this and come in and do something. Yeah, I love that. Of course. I love if I can add and get the budget of whatever they need to do. Yeah. But I'd rather not have all the, I don't need to be the lead of this.
但你客串了，比如在《王牌对王牌》之类的电影里。对，太搞笑了。就像，你得去，像那种东西，你知道的，当有一些小角色找上门来，你会想，我想支持这个项目，然后去客串一下做点什么。是的，我喜欢那样。当然。如果我能提供帮助，并拿到他们开展工作所需的预算，我当然很喜欢。但我宁愿不要所有的，我不需要成为这部电影的主演。
I'd rather make my movies and I like them small. I don't want to direct like a massive, this is probably the biggest it'll ever be. Like when I directed Chief of War, I directed four or five units. The finale is on the lava field. Dude, here's a crazy story. So you might ask this earlier, Will, like a crazy story about Chief of War. When we first wrote it, the whole finale is about, these two cousins fighting over the big island and the volcano goes off in history and it's literally
我宁愿拍我自己的电影，而且我喜欢小成本的。我不想导演一部宏大的，这大概是我拍过最大规模的了。就像我导演《战争酋长》时，我导演了四五个组。大结局是在熔岩地上。伙计，这里有个疯狂的故事。所以你可能之前问过这个，威尔，关于《战争酋长》的一个疯狂故事。当我们刚写完剧本时，整个大结局是关于，这两个表亲为争夺大岛而战，历史上火山爆发了，字面上看是
snowing ash and the volcano's coming down and the volcano it's it's kind of like let's just say it's 50,000 verse 10,000 and the volcano comes down and wipes out the person who lives in that territory and that's how Kamehamea won in history so when we wrote this I literally saw on the calendar in the production meeting, I go, boom, volcano's going to go off. And everyone was laughing me like, no, no, no, it's not going to go off. We cut to, we're there the night before. We're driving between Monoloa and Monocaia. And I tell my partner, I'm like, bro, it's going to go off.
下着火山灰雨，火山喷涌而下，火山，这有点像，我们就说是5万对1万吧，火山喷涌而下，吞没了住在那个领地的人，历史上卡美哈梅哈就是这样获胜的。所以当我们写这段时，我 literalmente（西班牙语：字面意思/简直）在制作会议的日历上看到了，我说，轰，火山要爆发了。每个人都笑着对我说，不，不，不，它不会爆发的。镜头一转，我们在那儿的头天晚上。我们开着车穿梭在冒纳罗亚火山和冒纳克亚火山之间。我告诉我的搭档，我说，兄弟，它要爆发了。
I know it. And about four hours later, production calls, Monoloa goes off, which is probably 10 plus years since it went off. Wow. Manoloa goes off. We obviously break because no one's worked during a volcano. So we're checking, you know, Eric, air quality and all those kind of things and they're like yeah we're good to go so the next day we go
我知道。大约四个小时后，制作部门打电话来，冒纳罗亚火山爆发了，距离它上一次爆发大概有10年之久吧。哇。冒纳罗亚火山爆发了。我们显然停工了，因为没人会在火山爆发期间工作。所以我们在检查，你知道的，埃里克，空气质量以及所有这些事情，他们说，是的，我们准备好了。所以第二天我们去
kill away it goes off that's the first time in human written history that both volcanoes went off i go and i shoot eight days i wanted to shoot the fight so it was like we're in the daytime and it goes into night i want to see the night i want to shift into blue light i want to i want to go through the sunset i want to go into blue light so i'd shoot the whole fight and reverse so we show up at four o'clock in the morning you're ushering in 300 extras 100 something and you're massive fucking battle dude yeah on lava fields so any anyone falls gets hurts where do you put the potty's how do you hide this i mean just all the schematics of like how do you shoot this massive epic piece in the area where it happened yeah so we shoot it there um i got about four to five units i'm directing at the
基拉韦亚火山爆发了，这是人类文字记载历史上两座火山同时爆发。我去拍了八天，我想拍这场打斗，所以感觉就像我们在白天拍摄，然后转入夜晚，我想看到夜晚，我想转换成蓝调光，我想，我想经历日落，我想进入蓝调光，所以我把整场打斗倒过来拍，这样我们在凌晨四点到达现场，你迎来了300名群演，100多个，你拍的是一场他妈的宏大战争，伙计。是的，在熔岩地上，所以任何人摔倒都会受伤，厕所放哪儿，怎么隐藏这些，我的意思是，所有关于如何在事发地点拍摄这部宏大史诗作品的技术方案，你知道的。所以我们在那里拍摄，嗯，我有大约四到五个组同时在
same time where i built it where i can shoot simultaneously so they can be used as extras in the back as I'm shooting this one as I'm shooting that so I kind of designed the whole fucking thing where I can and the 80's just like what what what I'm sitting in the production meeting and I have it all balanced out and yeah dude the fucking volcanoes this thing went off on the eighth day we end and the volcano stops the day we end both volcanoes end so were you getting the sort of the production value of those volcanoes going off we sent the people up to go shoot some stuff yeah but did you have ash coming down down on your shots and stuff?
导演，我搭建了场景，可以同时拍摄，这样当我在拍这个场景时，他们可以作为背景群演，当我在拍那个场景时也是如此，所以我基本上设计了整个他妈的拍摄过程，我可以，而副导演们就像是“什么，什么，什么”。我坐在制作会议上，把一切都安排得井井有条，是的，伙计，他妈的火山这东西在第八天爆发了，我们结束的那天，火山也停了，两座火山同时停了。所以你拍到了那些火山爆发的制作价值吗？我们派人上去拍了一些东西。是的，但你的镜头里有火山灰落下来吗？
No, no, we didn't have Ash coming down in our scene otherwise we wouldn't have been working because it was pretty bad for our health. But we had Ash and all that stuff coming down. So it's a huge massive scene where we shot it in reverse so that way we can shoot all our key characters in the same light. But it's all, yeah, it's completely in reverse. Wow.
不，不，我们的场景里没有火山灰落下来，否则我们就没法工作了，因为这对我们的健康相当有害。但我们确实有火山灰之类的东西落下来。所以这是一个非常巨大的场景，我们是倒着拍的，这样我们就可以在同一种光线下拍摄所有关键角色。但这一切都是，是的，完全是倒着拍的。哇。
It was meant to be. It's a massive feat. So the finale is like, that's my, that was like, I'm shooting the finale. And everyone's like, there's no way we'll pull this off. I'm like, I can't wait to see this. I've seen some of the posters around town. It looks awesome.
这是命中注定的。这是一个巨大的壮举。所以大结局就像是，那是我的，就像我在拍大结局。每个人都说，我们绝不可能搞定这个。我心想，我等不及要看这个了。我在镇上看过一些海报。看起来棒极了。
And it's all in our language. It's all in a Lelo, Hawaii. So you're like, you're going to be like, it's such a beautiful language. It's the most beautiful language. It's so rad. I mean, you're going to love it. Yeah, I can't wait to see it.
而且全部都是用我们的语言。全部都是夏威夷语（‘Ōlelo Hawaiʻi）。所以你会觉得，这真是一门美丽的语言。这是最美丽的语言。太酷了。我的意思是，你会爱上它的。是的，我等不及要看了。
We'll be right back. And back to the show. You were talking about shooting that. That's pretty rad that scene on the lava field and shooting that. And you've done a lot of kind of big, epic. scenes like that you've acted in a lot of them was in but like aquaman like didn't you have like underwater fight scenes basically oh yeah yi like how did you pull all that kind of stuff what was that process like
我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目。你刚才在谈论拍摄那个。熔岩地上的那场戏真是太酷了，还有拍摄那个。你拍过很多那种宏大的、史诗般的。像这样的场景，你演过很多这样的电影，比如海王，难道你没有那种水下打斗戏吗？哦，是的，天哪，你是怎么应付那种事情的，那个过程是怎样的？
lots of stuntmen i don't want to do it's it's brutal man it's brutal it's it's that's that's stuff's hard i mean fighting in a suit that putting that suit on i mean i would the best superhero in the world is lego batman come on black come on black dude my dude my son you're the best bad you're the greatest batman in the world the greatest well i mean you're the fucking best in the world come on well you are batman
大量的替身演员。我不想去演，太残酷了，伙计，太残酷了，那，那些真的很艰难。我的意思是，穿着那套衣服打斗，穿上那套衣服，我的意思是，世界上最伟大的超级英雄是乐高蝙蝠侠，拜托，布莱克，拜托，布莱克，伙计，我的儿子，你是最棒的巴，你是世界上最伟大的蝙蝠侠，最伟大的，好吧，我的意思是你是世界上他妈的最棒的，拜托，好吧，你就是蝙蝠侠。
thanks tell me more black that's a good impression and sometimes very very dark gray um listen uh that's very kind of you but i mean you've
谢谢，告诉我更多，布莱克。模仿得真像，有时候非常非常深灰。听着，呃，你太客气了，但我的意思是，你……
you know you're aquaman and you had you had to you know where all the put all that shit on do you like having to do that stuff like put all the fucking soon on no no i don't no but you do it yeah the tattoos it's all hard bro sorry it's all hard but then you go and do stuff but in the same time you do like like the like dune like going to working with uh denny i mean it must be i love those movies i love those movies i love those you guys hear what happened right now no no check this story out so i'm in i'm in japan
你知道的，你是海王，你不得不，你知道的，穿上所有那些破装备。你喜欢做那种事吗？像穿上所有他妈的战袍——不，不，我不喜欢。但你还是穿了。是的，还有纹身，一切都很难，兄弟。抱歉，一切都很难。但随后你又去拍了别的，但与此同时你也会拍像，像《沙丘》这样的电影，去和丹尼斯合作，那一定，我爱死那些电影了。我爱那些电影。你们听到刚才发生什么了吗？不，不，听听这个故事。所以我当时在日本，
with my son's dream is to go to japan so his 16th birthday we go with the whole family and i'm with him and i'm like gosh he he's trained martial arts his whole life he always wants to act i'm like you're never acting there's no way i'm not i'm not letting you act he does like school plays in tapanga right that's it that's the extension of like his acting skills yeah yeah you know um but i'm just like i don't want my kid child act i don't want you in this business blah blah blah you know obviously the mother's been through, like, no, you're not, you're not doing it. Look at baby. Yeah, it's just like, yeah, it's just like, but he grew up with his dad being this thing. He just loves it, but he loves martial
我儿子的梦想就是去日本，所以在他的16岁生日，我们全家一起去了，我和他在一起，我心想，天哪，他一辈子都在练武术，他一直想演戏，我就想，你绝不能演戏，没门，我不会，我不会让你演戏的。他在托潘加演过学校的话剧，对吧？就那样。这就是他演技的极限，对吧，对吧，你知道的，嗯。但我只是不想让我的孩子当童星，我不想让你进这个圈子，等等，你知道的，显然他妈妈经历过这些，就说，不，你不能，你不能这么做。看看宝贝。是的，就像是，是的，就像是，但他是在他爸爸拥有这种身份的环境中长大的。他就是喜欢，但他喜欢武
arts. So cut to, I'm like, he's 16, I really want, it's time for my son to be with me and travel, and maybe he can do school abroad, so I ask the mother, and we're like, yeah, well, if he can come with me, I would like him to come to Dune, because if he wants to really wants to learn acting, I'm like, we're going to be at Chalemay, we're going to be at Deney, we're to be with Zendaya, he should be watching his father, like, day and day out, I want his work ethic to be, like, mine of the Midwest. I want him to see how hard it is, getting up at this time, doing this. Like, it's hard, you know what I mean?
术。所以镜头一转，我想，他16岁了，我真的很希望，是时候让我的儿子和我一起旅行了，也许他可以在国外上学，所以我问他妈妈，我们觉得，好吧，如果他能跟我一起来，我希望他能来《沙丘》剧组，因为如果他真的想学表演，我就想，我们要和蒂莫西·柴勒梅德在一起，我们要和丹尼斯在一起，我们要和赞达亚在一起，他应该日复一日地看着他的父亲。我希望他的职业工具有着中西部人的底色。我希望他看到起早贪黑、做这件事有多难。这很难，你知道我的意思吗？
It's not digging ditches, but it's fucking hard. And when you have to do something over and over, and if you're doing a fight scene all day long, like, no, you go 10 rounds, 12 rounds, but, like, this is all day, and you're in a suit that weighs 40 pounds, and you're, like, it's brutal. Yeah. And so I want him to, like, understand the business. So he's begging me to learn all this stuff.
这虽然不是在挖沟，但它他妈的真的很难。当你不得不一遍又一遍地做一件事时，如果你一整天都在拍打现场，就像，不，你要打10个回合，12回合，但这却是一整天，而且你穿着一套重达40磅的战袍，你会觉得，这太残酷了。是的。所以我希望他能理解这个行业。所以他一直在求我，想学所有这些东西。
So, all right, fine. Well, let's send Uncle Kale. Kale, I did Minecraft with. I did Dune with. He's a producer. I'm sure you guys know him. And so Kale Boiters? Yeah, Kail Boitur.
好吧，好吧。那我们派凯尔叔叔去吧。凯尔，我和他一起拍过《我的世界》，我和他一起拍过《沙丘》。他是制片人。我确信你们认识他。所以是凯尔·博伊特？对，凯尔·博伊特。
And it's just like, he's, dear friend. I was like, listen, we'll send him a stunt, you know. So we taped something for Wolf. We send it in. And Kail's like, what the fuck? Dude, your son does? Because he's been doing it his whole life. And he's like, wow, he does this?
他就像是一个，亲爱的朋友。我当时就想，听着，我们会给他拍一段试镜视频，你知道的。所以我们为沃尔夫录了一些东西。我们把它寄了过去。凯尔就说，他妈的怎么回事？伙计，你儿子会这个？因为他从小到大一直在练。他就说，哇，他会这个？
I'm like, yeah, he's pretty good at. Do you think we can get him like a friendman role and he can do some fight scenes? and let him be on set. And he goes, dude, we're casting for the kids, for Shalamay and Zendaya's. Basically, like,
我说，对，他挺擅长的。你觉得我们能给他安排一个弗雷曼人的角色，让他拍几场打斗戏吗？让他留在剧组里。他说，伙计，我们正在为甜茶（柴勒梅德）和赞达亚的孩子们选角。基本上就像，
I guess it's like Skywalker and Leia. It's children of Dune. So it's the two kids. And I was like, all right, well, he doesn't, does he act?
我猜就像天行者和莱娅公主。是《沙丘》的孩子们。所以是两个孩子。我就想，好吧，他不，他会演戏吗？
I'm like, eh, you know, it's, you know, it's community theater. And anyways, they send it.
我说，呃，你知道的，就是社区剧院。不管怎样，他们把视频发了过去。
I'm in New Zealand. The mother's with him. He does his scene. you know we we we don't want i don't want to coach him at all right i don't know how to teach acting i don't have a fucking style it's just through sucking you know it's through sucking that i sucking a little less each year yeah that's my style like i've had 27 years of fucking sucking that right i figured it out so i don't really have a style yeah so i'm not going to i don't how to teach it so uh my dear friend cliff curtis who i looked up to and he was in the in the show
我在新西兰。他妈妈和他在一起。他演了那场戏，你知道，我们不想，我一点也不想指导他，对吧？我不知道怎么教表演，我他妈的根本没有什么风格，全靠演砸了，你知道的，是通过演砸了，每年少砸一点，对，那就是我的风格——我已经他妈的演砸了27年了，所以我琢磨出来了，所以我其实没有什么风格，对吧，所以我不知道怎么教。所以，我的好朋友克利夫·柯蒂斯，我很尊敬他，他也参演了这部剧，我就问他，你能跟我儿子聊聊表演吗？他跟他聊了一会儿，沃尔夫演了那场戏，我们录下来，寄了过去，他们他妈的太喜欢了，我就想，天哪，他……他们想让他去伦敦试镜。哦，天哪，我心想，伙计，什么？我不得不从新西兰飞往伦敦，我儿子和一个叫丹尼斯·维伦纽瓦的人在一个房间里，跟五个女孩一起试镜，试了三个半小时。我他妈压力太大了，真的。
with me i was like can you talk to my son a little bit about acting and he talks to him a little bit wolf does the scene we tape it we send it in and they fucking love it and i'm like holy shit uh he's like we want him to come to to london and test oh my god i'm like dude what and i had to fly from new zealand to london and my son goes into a room with denny valnew and it has to test with five girls and it's three and a half hours long I'm so fucking stressed out yeah and like
当时我就问，你能跟我儿子聊聊表演吗？他跟他聊了一会儿，沃尔夫演了这段戏，我们录下来发了过去，他们他妈的超级喜欢。我说，天哪，他就像是，我们想让他去伦敦试镜。天哪，我说，老兄，什么？我不得不从新西兰飞到伦敦，我儿子和丹尼斯·维伦纽瓦在一个房间里，和五个女孩一起试镜，持续了三个半小时。我压力大得要命，真的，就像
way more stress than you would be for yourself I mean bro like I don't even have like I'm fine no I'm freaking out because my son is just wild he's so wild and amazing but he just I guess he was beautiful
比你自己去试镜压力大得多。我的意思是，兄弟，我甚至都没有，我很好。不，我快急疯了，因为我儿子太狂野了。他太狂野、太棒了，但我猜他表现得很精彩。
like you know Mary Parenthood was texting me and he's killing he's doing great but he had to do like a really hard scene that even if I had to do that scene there's no way i could pull that off and to do that for the first time and this kid killed it and he did it on his own i didn't help him at all how about that and i'm doing fucking dune with my son right that's amazing i didn't know that i literally just we got the part premiere bro the premiere of of chief of war we flew to hawaii we did the premiere i think on the 18th we got on a plane that
就像，你知道的，玛丽·佩伦特（制片人）一直在发短信告诉我，他表现得很杀，他做得棒极了。但他不得不演一场非常难的戏，即使是我去演那场戏，我也绝对搞不定。而这是他第一次演戏，这小子太惊艳了，而且全凭他自己，我一点也没帮他。你觉得呢？而且我要和我儿子一起拍他妈的《沙丘》了！这太神奇了，我当时都不知道。我们刚参加完首映礼，兄弟，首映礼，《战争酋长》的首映礼，我们飞到夏威夷，我们办了首映礼，我想是在18号，我们那天晚上登机，我们在19号落地，我女儿的18岁生日是20号，我们21号起飞，我们在22号降落在布达佩斯。他23号就去上班了。天哪。他妈的他的第一场戏。没门。我裤子都快吓尿了。他跟赞达亚一起拍戏。
night we landed on the 19th my daughter's 18th was the 20th we flew out the 21st we landed in Budapest on the 22nd. He went to work on the 23rd. Jeez. His first goddamn scene. No way. Shooting my pants. He's with Zendaya.
他参演了。我心想，我的宝贝，16岁。而他表现得太惊艳了。我当时哭了。我整个人彻底崩溃了。我为他感到无比骄傲。他有没有说过，爸爸，你是对的？他有没有说过你是对的？
He's in it. I'm like, my baby, 16 years old. And he just killed it. I was crying. I was a fucking wreck. I was so proud of it. And did he ever go, did he go, dad, you were right? Did he say you were right?
这他妈真的太难了。他觉得太难了。他说，老爸，我现在对你充满敬意。而且他现在理解了每一个跟我工作的人，会说，是的，我需要帮助，我需要帮助，这些人就是帮助你的人。你没有跟他们的对手戏吧？我没有，但以后可能会有。但我当时就在那儿，看着他，你知道的，丹尼斯——我他妈太爱他了——他也很喜欢沃尔夫，而他表现得太出色了，
This is really fucking hard. He's so hard. He's like, it's so hard. He's like, pop on, so much. respect for you now and he and he understands every person that works with me now it's going like yeah i need help i need help these are the people that help you you don't have any scenes of them do you i don't this but in the future but i'm like i'm just there and i'm watching him and and you know denny who i fucking love and he's just like he's he's just he loves wolf and he's just doing a great job and
所以我当时的感觉太疯狂了，难以置信。是的，我心想，该死，伙计，我本来真不想让他走这条路，但我不骗你，他太优秀了。我一点也不意外。看看他的父母是谁。我也一点都不意外。而且我还觉得，你只希望你的孩子能比你更优秀。我心想，这混蛋将来，他会让我刮目相看的。他当下的专注力太强了。我有两件事想说。
so i'm like it's the craziest feeling how incredible yeah and i'm like god damn it dude i just didn't want him to do it but he's i'm not going to lie to you like he's so good i I'm not surprised. Look at his parents. I'm not surprised either. And I also think, like, you want your kids to just be better than you. And I'm like, this motherfucker's going to be, like, he's going to blow me away. He's so goddamn present. Two things I want to say.
第一，你为后人铺平了道路，因为你是个了不起的家伙。他这么优秀我一点也不意外，因为你很优秀。而且在这个时候你配得上这一切，这对我来说也不意外。想想你今年经历的一切，你在做的事。你有《战争酋长》，这是一部对你个人意义重大、关于你的家族的作品。现在你又有你的直系亲属——你的儿子来和你一起工作。这一定，你心中一定有一种不可思议的感觉，关于你今年所处的位置，仅仅是这一点，仅仅想想这一点，这真是太酷了。我开始拍《沙丘》，我
One is you've paved the way because you're a great dude. And it's no surprise to me that he's great because you're great. And it's no surprise to me that you deserve it in this time. Think about the year you've had that you're doing. You've got Chief of War, this thing that's really personal to you and about your family. And now you have your immediate family. son coming and working with you it must what an incredible feeling you must have in your heart this year about where you're at just just in that just think about that it's pretty rad i start dune i start
8月1日开机，这部作品也在这时上映。所以我8月1日开始拍《沙丘》，我去看了我儿子。是的，这太棒了，在那一天，是的，你付出了很多艰苦的努力，我告诉你，你知道吗，杰森，我跟你说个事，我儿子阿贝尔最近对我说的话。我的儿子阿贝尔，我们大家都认识的一个朋友，他们的生活中发生了一件事，而且是公开的，你知道的，这有点令人震惊。所以我的儿子阿贝尔来找我说，嘿，我听说那件事了，某某还好吧？我说，对，对，他们挺好的，都解决了。然后他说，你知道的，我当时在想，天哪，幸亏我们没有他们那么出名，因为你知道，对吧。然后我说，首先，你根本一点都不出名；第二，去你的吧，伙计。他是认真的。
august first and this comes out so i start dune august first i went and watched my son yeah it's great on the day it's yeah you you put in a lot of hard work i tell you you know what jason i'll tell you something that my son said to me recently my son abel a friend of ours uh whom we all know had it had something happened in their life and it was public and uh you know it's like sort of shocking so my son abel comes to me and he says uh hey i heard about that thing is so-and-so okay and i said yeah yeah they're fine it all worked and he goes you know i was just thinking man thank god we're not as famous as them because you know yeah and i go first of all you're not famous at all a yeah and b fuck you man And he meant it, too.
他当时就是觉得，谢天谢地我们不是他的家人。谢天谢地我们没那么出名。是的，情况就是这样，杰森？因为你真的无处可藏，对吧？我根本无处可藏。是的，所以你如何应对
He was just like, thank God we're not his family. Thank God we're not so famous. Yeah, how about that, Jason? Because you can't really hide. Can you? I can't hide at all. Yeah, and so how are you with that
粉丝互动、拍照以及诸如此类的事情？当有特定安排的时间时，我真的，我真的很擅长。是的。真正艰难的是，当我们，我们都是凡人。所以我会觉得，我没问题。
with fan interaction and taking photos and things like that? I really, I'm really good when it's like set for that time. Yeah. It's like really, here's the hard thing. It's like, when I'm, we're all human. So I'm like, I'm down.
但如果我和我的孩子们在一起，甚至不要，人们真的没有尊重感或者他们根本不过脑子。这会让孩子们感到非常不舒服。但如果我和我的孩子们在一起，我会说，别，是的，但我会说，我就像，你永远不会得到，我无法把我的注意力从这些我难得一见的可爱小家伙身上移开。是的。我会觉得，这是一个非常具有挑战性的导航问题，但与此同时，要么在那个时间去做，
But if I'm with my kids, don't even, it's just people don't have really respect or they don't really think. It just makes the kid so uncomfortable. But if I'm with my kids, I'm like, don't, yeah, but I'm like, I'm like, you're never going to get, I can't take my attention away from these beautiful things that I barely get to see. Yeah. I'm like, it's a very challenging thing to navigate, but at the same time, it's that time to do it
要么如果我不在，如果我自己一个人，我就会想，是的，当然可以。但最酷的事情是，我喜欢有小孩的时候，因为就像，比如《我的世界》，现在他们觉得，从《海王》变成了我现在成了垃圾工，我知道你们可能还没看过《我的世界》，但《我的世界》里我就像个垃圾工，所以这他妈可爱得要命，所有这些小孩子
or if I'm not, if I'm by myself, I'm like, yeah, hell yeah. But the cool thing is, is like, I love it when it's kids because it's like, my, Minecraft like right now they're like it went from Aquaman and then it went into like I'm garbage man now I know you guys probably haven't seen Minecraft but Minecraft I'm like the garbage man now and so it's fucking cute as shit so all these little kids
都会喊垃圾工，我就会说，嘿，怎么啦？所以我很乐意跟孩子们互动，但如果是一个成年壮汉，我会想，请，请给我买杯啤酒吧，对吧，是的，别搞得那么奇怪，就当普通朋友相处。我猜，我猜续集大概正在筹备中，对吧？你们什么时候
are like garbage man and I'm like yeah what's up so I'll take kids to the kids but it's a grown ass man I'm like just just buy me a beer yeah right yeah try not to be weird about it just hang out like I would imagine I would imagine the sequel to that is probably brewing right when do you
开始拍那个？哦，伙计，我们马上就要投入进去了。是的。我的意思是，我可能三月份就要进组拍这个混蛋了。看看你，约翰尼·特许经营大户。我太喜欢了。我知道。跟我说说看，伙计。
When do you guys start that? Oh, dude, we're right into it. Yeah. It's like, I mean, I'm into this motherfucker in March maybe. Look at you, Johnny Franchise. I love it. I know. Tell me about it, man.
别他妈的让狂热粉丝砸门了。希望《酋长》能续拍。真的吗？基督啊。对，我也把一切都搬到新西兰了。我心想，新西兰和夏威夷，我正在那里和克利夫以及塔伊加一起建造工作室。所以我们正试图，我们正试图……不会吧？
Don't get fucking fastened barking down the door. Hopefully Chief goes again. Really? Christ. Yeah, I moved everything to New Zealand, too. I'm like, New Zealand and Hawaii, I'm building studios down there with Cliff and Tyca. So we're trying to, we're trying to like. No way.
对，所以我只想一切都迅速推进。太棒了。你去过新西兰吗？我从没去过。我小时候，我很想去。想回去吗？那是你的家吗？家现在是美国的蒙大拿州还有新西兰，所以，是的。哇，我在夏威夷还有产业，但基本上我正试图在夏威夷和新西兰之间建造工作室。太棒了，太棒了。所有东西都在那里拍。这只是
Yeah, so I just want to be boom, boom, boom. That's great. Have you ever been in New Zealand? I've never. When I was a little kid, I'd love to go. go back are you is that where home is home is now montana in the states and uh new zealand so yeah wow and i in in hawai still i have but it's like i'm basically trying to build studios between hawai and new zealand that's amazing that's amazing shoot everything there it's just
当你到了某个阶段，比如，生活质量，我想去哪里？我想和谁在一起？你知道的，我不想，这仍然有税收优惠，我会觉得，这就是我想呆的地方。所以，如果每个人都能来这里，我们在新西兰制作了《我的世界》。我们在那里制作了《战争酋长》。我制作了即将上映的《破坏小队》。就像，我把所有的东西都在新西兰制作了，或者拿到夏威夷去。太棒了。你最喜欢和你的孩子们一起做什么？我正想问你，你工作那么忙？听起来像是，你在闲暇时间做什么？但是，显然，为了陪伴家人，当你不在工作时，你最喜欢和孩子们或家人一起做什么？我的意思是，我们去攀岩。所以这就变成，
you get to a certain place from like yeah the quality of life where do i want to be who don't want to be with you know i don't want to like it's still tax incentives and i'm like this is where i want be. And so, like, if everyone can come down here, we made Minecraft in New Zealand. We made Chief of War down there. I made wrecking crew, which is coming out. Like, I just made everything in New Zealand or it's going to go to Hawaii. That's great. What's your favorite thing to do with your, I was going to ask you, what you work so much? It sounds like, like, what do you do in your downtown? But, like, obviously, to spend time with family, what's your favorite thing to do with your kids or with family when you're not working? I mean, we rock climb. So it's like,
我一辈子都带孩子们去攀岩。所以我们去攀岩，这让我们保持在户外活动。攀岩、冲浪或者……这是个真正的男子汉，杰森。你应该感到羞愧。我真的是。你知道的，我小时候经常攀岩，
I tell my kids out of rock climbing the whole life. So we rock climbing, like, that just keeps us in the outdoors. And rock climbing. surfing or... This is a real man, Jason. You should be ashamed to yourself. I really am. You know, I used to rock climb when I was a little kid,
但现在随着年龄增长，我的手疼得太厉害了。岩石里没有任何柔软的东西。只有粗糙。就像我希望我的手保持强壮和坚韧。我知道。我看到你一根手指上贴着创可贴，我就想，那简直，
but now it hurts my hands too much as I get older. It's just, there's nothing soft about a rock. It's just scratchy. It's like my hands to be strong and tough. I know. I see you got a Band-Aid on the one finger and I'm like, that would just,
如果我手指上贴着创可贴，我大概得取消播客了。你总是咬牙坚持过去，对吧？然后就是音乐，伙计。我开始和我的孩子们一起玩音乐。我女儿会唱歌。所以我开始玩音乐，他们把我拉去弹贝斯，因为他们两个都开始玩其他乐器了。
I'd have to cancel the podcast if I had a band-aid on my finger. You push right through it, don't you? And then music, man. I started playing my kids. My daughter was a sing. So I started playing music, and they kind of moved me into bass because they both started doing everything else.
我就是喜欢和他们一起玩音乐。这像是个家庭乐队吗？嗯，这不算是家庭乐队。我开始做，我开始搞，我有一家伏特加公司，所以我，呃，我不知道。它叫Halif，Relief。它叫Maley。Maly。Relief。
And I just love playing music with them. Is it like a family band? Well, it's not a family band. I started making a, I started doing, I have a vodka company, so I, uh, I don't know It's called Halif, Relief. It's called Maley. Maly. Relief.
这其实是个挺不错的伏特加名字。我正盯着帽子看。我想看看。看起来不像，不。Maly。Mealy。对。所以我们在蒙大拿州有一家伏特加公司
That's actually a good name for a lot. I'm trying to look at the hat. I'm trying to see. It looks like, no. Maly. Mealy Yeah So we have a vodka company
所以这种感觉真好，就像有这样的聚会，你和大家聚在一起，我们一起玩音乐，我们演奏我们最喜欢的歌曲，所以我们演奏齐柏林飞艇、黑色安息日和红辣椒乐队，
In Montana And so it's been nice to Like have these gatherings Where you get together with everyone And we play music And we play our favorite songs So we play Zeppelin and Sabbath And Chili Peppers
还有王子乐队和僵尸乐队。都很适合弹贝斯。所有这些，所有这些乐队里都有约翰·保罗·琼斯。太不可思议了。你有一家伏特加公司。你正在新西兰和夏威夷之间建造工作室。你在导演电影。你在写电视剧。而且在电视剧里演戏，还在大约八个特许经营系列里演戏。你看起来对此一切都泰然处之。而且你看起来真的很开心。是的，而且就像，是的。
And Prince and zombie All great for the bass All those All those groups have John Paul Jones Incredible You've got a vodka company You're building a studio
我的意思是，什么，什么会惹恼你？就像，你看起来，你挺好的，当然，随便吧。我们迟到了吗？那挺酷的。我等你就是了。我挺生气的。为了这个角色，我得减掉一大堆体重，我正为这个角色做准备呢。你知道最逗的是什么吗？
Between New Zealand and Hawaii You're directing movies You're writing series And acting in series and acting in like eight franchises. And you seem so, like, chill about it all. And you seem really happy. Yeah, and like, yeah.
好吧。但那是每个人的日常。我得加把劲。我得照顾好自己。你是怎么，你最喜欢的是什么？你们最近过得怎么样？听着，我46岁了。你们是，你知道的，你看。
I mean, what, what pisses you want? Like, you seem like, you're fine, sure, whatever. Are we late? That's cool. I'll just wait for you. I'm pretty pissed. I got to lose a bunch of weight that I'm getting ready for this role. You know what's about it?
你知道，你说你55岁。我们比你大10岁。对，对，比我大10岁。我心想……你最喜欢的减重方法是什么？你知道的，我……不吃饭还是运动？所以，我不运动，而且我，我想吃什么就吃什么。
All right. But that's everyone's thing. I got to do a little extra. I got to take care of myself. How do you, what's your favorite? How was it going with you guys? Like, listen, I'm 46. You guys are, you know, you see.
我想吃什么就吃什么。而且我也喝酒。你可以……基本上，当我戒酒、饮食健康并开始运动时，就会瘦下来。好吧，明白了。哦，对了，你的身体一定吃不消。通常情况下，我只是维持现状，非到万不得已我不这么做。对。
You know, you said you're 55. We got 10 years on you. Yeah, yeah, 10 years on me. I'm like... What's your favorite way of dropping pounds? You know, I... Not eating or exercise? So, I don't exercise, and I don't, and I eat whatever I want.
但我的问题是，和你要戒掉的所有那些东西一样，哦，你做这个做那个，我唯一不做的就是——我没有好好照顾自己。好吧，你会的，你还有时间。对，对，你还有时间，你得去面对，比如，到了某个特定的人生阶段，只要经历过一次肾结石，就能改变你的一生。哦，我还没得过呢。好吧，好吧，谢谢你，老爷子。听着，我觉得，但是现在有多少人在听，心想，他妈的莫莫甚至都不健身，但他看起来——我知道，我真想一头撞死。一定有过那么一段时间，一定有过那么一段时间你是个健身狂，为了那个角色练出了那一身肌肉。不，只有当我，你知道的，我从小玩滑板长大。
And I eat whatever I want. So, and I drink. You can have a... Basically, when I stop drinking and I eat smart and I exercise, I lose weight. Okay, gotcha. Oh, yeah, your body must go into shot. Generally, I just keep it like, I don't do it until I have to. Yeah.
我以前是个滑板少年和攀岩者。所以当我拍《野蛮人柯南》时，他们逼着我练成那样，他们让我训练并学习所有这些。我的意思是，为了角色你必须这么做。当然。这就是表演的伟大之处。他们会教你所有这些新东西。所以，你知道的，你学会了。然后显然为了《海王》，我不得不进行训练，你知道的，你和所有这些顶尖教练在一起。
but I my problem is like with all the things that you're taking off like oh you do this do this the thing that I don't do is I don't take care of myself well you will you will you still got time yeah yeah so you got time you got to go like oh this is a certain point where you take care of one one one kidney stone you'll change your life oh haven't had one yet yeah okay well thanks granddad listen I think but but how many people are listening right now going fucking momo doesn't even work out and he looks like I know I'm gonna fucking throw myself There must have been a time, there must have been a time when you were a gym rat and you put on all that size on that claim. No, it's only when I was like, you know, I grew up skateboarding.
但我不想那样生活。而且我不觉得，我，所以我所做的是，我在我们的训练设施里建造攀岩馆，因为我不想做仰卧起坐，我也不想，我只想去攀岩。是的，世界上最大的乐趣之一就是食物。是的，我只是为了做更多事而去攀岩。嘿，伙计，放松点。为了，就像，去做你喜欢做的事。是的，而且，是的，你以为自己身材很好，直到你尝试做一个引体向上，而攀岩能锻炼出那种能力，对吧？
I was a skateboarding and rock climber. So when I did Conan, they made me put all that, they made me train and learn all that stuff. I mean, you do it for roles. Sure. And that's what's great about acting. They teach all these new things. And so, you know, you learn that. And then obviously for Aquaman, I had a train and, you know, you're with all these best trainers.
就是那种。是的，我只是尝试，我只是想在做自己喜欢的事情时获得快乐。所以，我的意思是，就像我说的，做我热爱的事情。我只是觉得，如果我去举重，我可能更容易受伤。如果我现在真的举重，重量也会非常轻，或者我做一些壶铃训练，这确实对我的腿部力量很有帮助。但我用的重量相当轻。你可以通过只举筷子来避免受伤，就像肖恩一样，你知道的。
But I don't want to live like that. And I don't find, like, I, so what I did is I would build rock climbing gyms in our training facilities because I don't want to do sit-ups and I don't want to, I would just rock-climed. Yeah, one of the greatest joys in the world is food. Yeah, I would just rock climb to do more. Hey, man, relax. To, like, kind of like, the things that you love to do. Yeah, and, yeah, you think you're in shape until you try a pull-up, and that's, that's a lot of rock climbing makes, right?
但我不想那样生活。而且我觉得，我，所以我做的就是在我们的训练设施里建造攀岩馆，因为我不想做仰卧起坐，我不想，我只想去攀岩。是的，世界上最快乐的事情之一就是食物。是的，我只是通过攀岩来做更多的事。嘿，伙计，放松点。去做那些你喜欢做的事。是的，而且，是的，你觉得自己体型不错，直到你尝试做一个引体向上，而攀岩能锻炼出很多这种能力，对吧？
It's just like. Yeah, it's just, I just try, I just want to have fun doing things I like to do. So, I mean, like, I say physical doing things I love to do. I just, like, I think I probably get hurt more lifting weights. If I do lift weights, it's very light now, or I do, like, kettlebells, which has really helped, like, just for, like, my, like, legs. But I do pretty light weight. You can avoid injury by just lifting chopsticks, like Sean, you know.
就像是。是的，这只是，我只是尝试，我只是想在做自己喜欢的事情时获得乐趣。所以，我的意思是，就像我说的那样，做我热爱的体能活动。我只是觉得，我举重受伤的概率可能更高。如果我现在做力量训练，重量会非常轻，或者我会用壶铃，这确实对我的腿部很有帮助。但我用的重量很轻。只要像肖恩一样只用筷子夹东西，你就可以避免受伤，你知道的。
Into sodium. I'm just thinking, here we got two guys who both don't work out and eat whatever they want. And one is Jason Mamoa and one's Sean Hayes. I'd love to see it. Just a speedo shot side by side the two of you. It'd be so good. Although, J.B., you were talking about
说到钠。我只是在想，这里有两个完全不锻炼、想吃什么就吃什么的人。一个是杰森·莫玛，一个是肖恩·海斯。我很想看他们俩同框。如果能看到你们俩并排穿着泳裤的照片，那一定太棒了。不过，J.B.，你刚才说到
you were lifting really lightweights recently and you were saying how hard it was. That lasted three days. Did it really? It did, yeah. I'll get back at it though. I've had a burger every day for the last three days.
你最近举的重量非常轻，还说这有多难。那只持续了三天。真的吗？是真的，对。不过我会重新开始的。过去三天里我每天都吃一个汉堡。
Really? You're great. Yeah. Babe, do you work out? No, not really. I mean, I do cardio, but I don't lift weight and I should. I mean, like, when you're directing,
真的吗？你太棒了。是啊。宝贝，你锻炼吗？不，其实不怎么锻炼。我的意思是，我有做有氧运动，但我没举重，其实我应该去的。我的意思是，当你在导演时，
it's so hard. The hard thing for me is like, I'm such a, I come from such an art. artist mentality where it's like it's really hard to balance the physicality when I'm like I'm giving everything to right these things that you're doing you're up too early too to yeah and the thing is like I don't sleep much anyways which is fine it's just I don't if I if I if I burn out doing this to for just I just don't take care of myself keep doing whatever you're doing whatever you're doing yeah whatever you're killing it just yeah my favorite thing one time memo you and I were in
太难了。对我来说最难的是，我带有强烈的艺术。艺术家的心态，所以真的很难平衡体力，当我觉得自己正在全力以赴地写你们在做的这些东西时，你们起得也太早了，对，而且关键是，我本来就睡得不多，这没关系，只是我如果不，如果我，如果我因为做这个而精疲力竭，哪怕只是一会，我只是不照顾好自己，继续做你正在做的事，不管你做什么，太棒了，继续，我最喜欢的一件事，有一次，莫玛，你和我
Vegas we were at for like cinema con or something we were on a shuttle bus yeah we were going we were going back to the airport and he had like a rucksack like a roughly hewn rucksack and it was just filled with loose beers it was the it was the greatest I'm like he's got a bag with him and I was like
在拉斯维加斯，我们去参加电影产业大会什么的，我们坐在一辆穿梭巴士上，对，我们要回机场，他背着一个类似粗呢背包的东西，里面塞满了散装啤酒，那真是，太棒了，我就想，他居然随身带了个包，然后我想
oh it's a cooler so smart I know so jealous all right what are you going to do the rest of the day today Jason you got you got the evening I go have dinner with my lady all right yeah I'm going to go just have a nice
哦，是个保温箱，太聪明了。我懂，太嫉妒了。好了，杰森，今天剩下的时间你打算怎么过？你有晚上的安排，我要和我美女去吃晚饭。好啊，我打算去过一个美好的
romantic dinner my lady who's your lady i should know should we adrea adre arjona andre arjona yeah nice name movie yeah she's uh she's she's doing a movie thomas crown affair right now
浪漫晚安，和我的美女。谁是你的美女？我应该知道吗？是埃莎·冈萨雷斯吗？艾莎·冈萨雷斯，对，好名字。电影，对，她现在在拍一部电影《龙凤斗智》（The Thomas Crown Affair）
oh wow so we're gonna go have a nice dinner and then i go back to budapest to go back to dude yeah unbelievable i can't wait the kids are in the kids are in budapest so we're gonna be together and uh wolfie's working and low my daughter lola's there so her friends are coming over and we're just uh celebrating because I get them in the summer,
哦，哇，所以我们要去吃一顿丰盛的晚餐，然后我要回布达佩斯，回去陪老兄，对，难以置信，我迫不及待了。孩子们都在布达佩斯，所以我们要团聚了，而且沃尔菲在工作，我的女儿萝拉也在那儿，所以她的朋友们要来，我们只是在庆祝，因为夏天我能陪他们，
so we're going to go do fun stuff, having my birthday here in a couple days, so big party. Yeah, you have plans for your birthday? I think he was going to stay at the house, maybe get a DJ and just, like, eat. You're going to stay at the house with a DJ? A DJ at the house and just eat.
所以我们要去做有趣的事情，过几天我还要在这里过生日，所以会有个大派对。是啊，你对生日有什么计划吗？我想他会留在家里，可能请个DJ，然后，就吃东西。你要留在家里办派对，还要请个DJ？在家里请个DJ，然后吃东西。
Get Scottie. Scotty, I snuggle. My husband DJs sometimes. Sure he does. Send him over. He's in London. He'll do the gate. Listen, we'll make a deal here.
找斯科蒂。斯科蒂，我抱抱。我丈夫有时当DJ。他当然会。派他过来吧。他在伦敦。他会看大门的。听着，我们在这达成个协议。
Momoa, you're going to have to wait till, what, 50 for the big one, right? I mean, I feel like that's, that's, when you get to our age, you got to wait for like 50, 60, 70, 80 for the big ones. You can't do it every year, right? Yeah. No, I just think being, I'm like, I'm with some really cool friends that I haven't seen a long time. How long is it? You haven't seen us for a long time. Can we get an invite?
莫玛，你得等到50岁才能过大寿吧？我的意思是，我觉得当你到了我们这个年龄，你得等到50、60、70、80岁才办大派对。你不能每年都办，对吧？对。不，我只是觉得，我能和一些很久没见的好朋友在一起。有多久了？你很久没见我们了。我们能收到邀请吗？
I would love for you guys to come. We like to party. It's Budapest, so it's like, it's pretty far. We got mileage. You're always invited. Listen, dude, continue success. One of the all-time great dudes, and you deserve all of it. Honestly.
我很希望你们来。我们喜欢开派对。那是布达佩斯，所以挺远的。我们有里程。你们随时受邀。听着，老兄，祝你持续成功。史上最棒的家伙之一，你配得上这一切。真的。
I'm so happy for you and you see it looks so great and you seem so happy and just continued I'm so psyched that you and your son get to do this just all of it is great you're a raised sunshine dude I can't wait I'm a huge tune fan I can't wait for the time yeah I can't wait for you guys yeah chief of war Apple TV on August first as well I mean just just all of it all of it's so rare congratulations buddy keep it up yeah keep going thanks payment all right guys all right nice to see you see you pal all right nice going big hug soon all right to see you hello bye pal
我为你感到高兴，你看上去状态极佳，显得如此幸福，希望这种状态能持续下去。我太高兴你和你的儿子能一起做这件事了，一切都太棒了。你是个小太阳，老兄，我等不及了。我是《沙丘》的超级粉丝，我等不及了。是的，我也等不及你们了。Apple TV的《战神》（Chief of War）也是八月一日上线。我是说，这一切，这一切都太难得了，祝贺你，老兄，继续加油！是啊，继续冲，谢谢支付。好了，伙计们，好的，很高兴见到你们，再见，伙计。好的，再见，很快给我们一个大大的拥抱。好的，再见，拜拜，伙计。
he slammed it he's a slammer i love it yeah nice going a while you know i thought it might have been baroque obama i'm i was pleasantly surprised it was jason mamoa you know those are the two hawaians that you know that's it that and king command mail but he's gone so um yeah that that that was great this is great oh it's such a war the warmest guy really fun yeah just so cool down to earth yeah so so good i love the hit that i love that his pants came down at shit fuck Is that what it's called? Yeah. At shit fucks, you got taken from behind with his shorts down.
他太猛了，他真是个猛男，我喜欢。好样的，有一会儿，你知道的，我以为会是巴拉克·奥巴马，我惊喜地发现是杰森·莫玛，你知道的，那是你们认识的两个夏威夷人，就这样，还有卡美哈美哈国王，但他已经不在了，所以，嗯，那真的很棒，这太棒了。哦，他真是个最热情的人，真的很有趣，太酷了，脚踏实地，好极了，我喜欢他的裤子掉下来的时候，卧槽。那是这么叫的吗？对。在shit fucks酒吧，你从后面被偷袭，短裤都掉下来了。
Wow. It was just the net result of all that. That's when I perked up. We might want to revisit the transcript on that, Jay. I don't know. You know what I mean? And also, you want to fall on the wrong side of Mamoa? I mean, you know.
哇。这只是这一切的最终结果。那时我才振作起来。杰，我们可能得重新查一下那段对话记录。我不知道。你知道我的意思吗？而且，你想站在莫玛的对立面吗？我的意思是，你懂的。
But you truly thought shitfucks was in Chelsea. Is it not? I thought, but wait, you know, it's great about him as like, I had no idea he was that prolific in this business. Dude, he's a busy man. Yeah, he's just doing it all. Big, huge star. Yeah, turns out. Just a guy trying to mind his own business.
但你真的以为shit fucks在切尔西吗？难道不是吗？我以为，但是你知道，关于他最棒的一点是，我根本不知道他在这一行这么高产。老兄，他是个大忙人。是的，他什么都在做。超级大明星。是的，原来如此。只是一个努力过好自己生活的人。
And then you're like complaining about tech rehearsals. Yeah, I know. Hey, yeah, when do you go up, Shawnee? It's got to be close. Two days, three days. Three days. Oh, my God. I can't wait to see you.
然后你还在抱怨技术彩排。对，我知道。嘿，肖妮，你什么时候上台？应该快了吧。两天，三天。三天。哦，天哪。我迫不及待想看你的演出。
Oh, my God. I don't normally have my wearing my hair like this. Well, we're not talking about the hair right now. You look great. We're talking about three days. Yeah, yeah. J.B., you're not going over, right? J.B., we're going to go over and see him.
哦，天哪。我平时不这样弄头发的。好吧，我们现在不谈头发。你看起来真棒。我们在说三天。对，对。J.B.，你不会过去的，对吧？J.B.，我们要过去看他的演出。
Yeah, no, I saw it. It's good. Yeah, that's fine. Yeah. I saw it in New York. And plus, I was just there in London, staying with him. Okay, walking the fucking stairs. I liked it the first time.
对，没有，我看过了。挺好的。对，那很好。对。我在纽约看过。而且，我刚去过伦敦，就住在她那里。好吧，爬那些该死的楼梯。我第一次挺喜欢它的。
I preferred it in the States. I'm a fan of the original. Yeah, I know, I'm excited. You got so beleaguered, the guy. Yeah, go ahead. No, I was just going to do a bye. Oh. No, we know.
我更喜欢美国版的。我是原版的粉丝。对，我知道，我很兴奋。你被折腾得好惨，老兄。是的，说吧。不，我只是想说个再见。哦。不，我们知道。
We saw you look out the window. Well, no, I was thinking, I was like, you know, I didn't, I knew. I didn't know he was from Hawaii. I thought it was like, but, you know, Aloha, not only means hello and in Hawaiian. Sure. What else does it mean? What does it mean? No, no.
我们看到你往窗外看了。好吧，不，我在想，我就觉得，你知道，我不知道。我不知道他是夏威夷人。我以为是，但是，你知道，“阿洛哈”（Aloha）不仅在夏威夷语里是你好和的意思。当然。那它还意味着什么？它意味着什么？不，不。
It means something like, bye! Bye! Bye! Oh my God! Oh, hi! Aloha! Smartless. Smartless.
它的意思是类似，再见！再见！再见！哦，天哪！哦，嗨！阿洛哈！Smartless。Smartless。
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry. Smart less. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smartless由Rob Armjarf、Bennett Barbico和Michael Grant Terry100%有机纯手工打造。Smart less。谢谢。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。